From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. So one of our producers, Zoe Chace, had this whole plan to follow this senator for a year as he ran for re-election. And it was an interesting story because the senator is a Republican who does not like the president. And he talks about that all the time, and the president seems to despise him.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我们的制片人之一佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）曾有个完整的计划，打算跟随一位参议员一年，记录他竞选连任的过程。这个故事很有意思，因为这位参议员是一位不喜欢总统的共和党人，他经常谈论这一点，而总统似乎也很鄙视他。
So would he be able to convince Republicans to vote for him? Republicans still overwhelmingly support the president. Zoe wanted to see him make the pitch. And then something happened that threw a wrench in her plans. Zoe?
那么，他能说服共和党人投票给他吗？共和党人绝大多数仍然支持总统。佐伊想看他如何进行游说。然而，后来发生的一件事打乱了她的计划。佐伊？
Yeah, he resigned. He stopped running for office.
是的，他辞职了。他不打算继续竞选公职了。
Yeah, so that kind of put the kibosh on that story.
是的，那件事让这个报道计划彻底泡汤了。
There wasn't a story anymore.
故事已经不复存在了。
Yeah. Explain who this is.
是的。解释一下他是谁。
Jeff Flake, senator from Arizona-- he resigned from the Senate on October 24. And that day, he gave this big resignation speech on the floor of the Senate kind of slamming the president. In this political moment, it got a lot of attention.
杰夫·弗莱克（Jeff Flake），来自亚利桑那州的参议员。他在10月24日辞去了参议院的职务。那天，他在参议院发表了那场重大的辞职演说，痛斥了总统。在当时的政治氛围下，这引起了极大的关注。
It is time for our complicity and our accommodation of the unacceptable to end. We must never regard as normal the regular and casual undermining of our democratic norms and ideals-- the personal attacks, the flagrant disregard for truth and decency.
是我们停止共谋和容忍不可接受之事的时候了。我们绝不能认为对民主准则和理想的经常性、随意性破坏是正常的——包括那些人身攻击，以及对真理和正派的公然蔑视。
And this attitude, you might say, is the reason he had to resign. He'd been very outspoken about the president. He wrote a whole book calling the president basically unfit for office and a menace to our democracy. And that's why he couldn't win an election in Arizona.
你可能会说，这种态度正是他不得不辞职的原因。他一直对总统直言不讳。他写了一整本书，基本上称总统不适合担任公职，是民主的威胁。这就是他无法在亚利桑那州赢得选举的原因。
There were polls that showed he only had a 22% approval rating among Trump voters in Arizona. So how could he win a Republican primary? So the story is dead.
民调显示，他在亚利桑那州的特朗普选民中的支持率仅为22%。所以他怎么可能赢得共和党初选呢？因此，这个报道计划告吹了。
But then in December, something happens that changes everything.
但到了十二月，发生了一件事，改变了一切。
Yeah, this thing happens where a Democrat gets elected to Senate in Alabama, which is weird. Doug Jones becomes the senator of Alabama against accused child molester Roy Moore. And that changes things because John McCain is out for medical leave.
是的，发生了一件事：一名民主党人在阿拉巴马州当选参议员，这很奇怪。道格·琼斯（Doug Jones）击败了被控性侵儿童的罗伊·摩尔（Roy Moore），成为了阿拉巴马州的参议员。这改变了局势，因为约翰·麦凯恩（John McCain）当时因病请假。
The Republican majority in the Senate is now down to one vote-- 49 Democrats, 50 Republicans. Any one Republican senator can theoretically stop a bill by voting with the other side. And suddenly, this one renegade Senator, Jeff Flake, not beholden to the president, has a lot of power.
参议院的共和党多数席位现在仅剩一票优势——49名民主党人对50名共和党人。理论上，任何一名共和党参议员都可以通过加入对方阵营来阻止法案通过。突然之间，这位不受总统控制的叛逆参议员杰夫·弗莱克，掌握了巨大的权力。
Zoe.
佐伊。
Hi. Hi, Senator.
你好。你好，参议员。
Long time no talk.
好久不见。
So how does it feel to be the most powerful senator in Congress right now?
那么，身为目前国会最有权势的参议员，感觉如何？
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
Seriously.
认真的。
Where'd you get that?
这话从何说起？
A lot of people.
很多人都这么说。
[CHUCKLES] You're running in strange circles, then.
[轻笑] 那你一定是身处奇怪的圈子里了。
It does give you more leverage though, right? I mean, are you feeling that?
但这确实让你有了更多筹码，对吧？我是说，你有感觉到吗？
Well, I don't feel it yet because it hasn't happened yet. But when the new senator is seated, then perhaps.
嗯，我还感觉不到，因为事情还没发生。但等新任参议员就职后，也许会吧。
This is as much as you'll get Jeff Flake to admit he's excited about something. He is an understated guy. I can tell he is pleased. Flake's essential for Republicans to get to 50 votes. For all the things, they need 60 votes for in the Senate. He has new leverage there as well.
这就是杰夫·弗莱克能承认自己对某事感到兴奋的极限了。他是个内敛的人。但我看得出他很高兴。弗莱克对于共和党人达到50票至关重要。对于参议院需要60票才能通过的所有法案，他也因此拥有了新的筹码。
And so Zoe asks Jeff Flake, could she watch him try to execute this new-found leverage? And he said sure, and she's been following him since then. Because Flake is in this interesting position.
于是佐伊问杰夫·弗莱克，她能否观察他如何运用这一新发现的筹码。他说没问题，从那时起她就开始追踪报道他。因为弗莱克处于一个有趣的位置。
Any Republican who is up for re-election this year, there are all kinds of things they cannot say or do because Donald Trump and his voters will punish them. They can't cross the president. They can't cozy up to Democrats. But because Flake isn't running, it's like he's bulletproof. It's like he has this superpower.
任何今年要竞选连任的共和党人，都有各种各样的话不能说，各种事不能做，因为唐纳德·特朗普和他的选民会惩罚他们。他们不能违抗总统，也不能与民主党人走得太近。但因为弗莱克不参选，他就好像是刀枪不入的。他仿佛拥有某种超能力。
He can do anything he wants, say anything he wants, take risks to get things done. And he decides to do something with that new-found power and leverage. And what he decides to do is pass what could be his very last bill. And the thing he goes for in this bill is DACA-- legal status for kids who were brought to the United States by their parents, and then grew up here in the United States.
他可以随心所欲地做事，畅所欲言，为了达成目标而冒险。他决定利用那股新获得的力量和筹码做点什么。他决定要做的，是尝试通过可能是他任期内的最后一份法案。他在这份法案中着眼的目标是DACA（童年抵美者暂缓遣返计划）——为那些年幼时被父母带到美国，并在美国长大的孩子们争取合法身份。
It's 800,000 people who have signed up officially as DACA kids. Super popular issue-- 80% of the country supports giving the Dreamers legal status. The president said he wanted it. The majority of the Senate wants it. If anything should be able to pass, it should be DACA.
有80万人正式注册为DACA受益者。这是一个超受欢迎的问题——全国80%的人支持给予“梦想生”合法身份。总统说他想要这个结果。参议院多数人也想要。如果有什么法案理应通过，那一定是DACA。
So Zoe followed him trying to pass DACA for four months. She talked to him when he would come off the Senate floor, when he was heading to the White House. She hung out with him in his office when he was stressed out late at night.
所以，佐伊跟了他四个月，看他努力推动DACA。当他走出参议院大厅或前往白宫时，她都会与他交谈。当他深夜感到压力时，她就在他的办公室陪他。
And of course, you probably know Flake, he does not succeed, right? DACA does not pass. The president tweeted, in fact just last weekend in all caps, no more DACA deal. DACA is dead. And so today on our show, what you're going to hear is you're going to hear Jeff Flake fail.
当然，你可能知道弗莱克，他没有成功，对吧？DACA没有通过。事实上，就在上周末，总统在推特上用全大写字母写道：不会再有DACA协议了。DACA已死。所以今天在我们的节目中，你将听到的是杰夫·弗莱克的失败。
And just to say it, of course, it is not a big surprise to anybody that Congress is dysfunctional. And it's hard to get anything done in Congress. But watching somebody actually trying to do something, to pass a bill, you see how the nature of Congress' dysfunction has changed in ways that are very specific to Donald Trump.
顺便提一下，国会功能失调对任何人来说都不是什么大新闻。在国会中达成任何事情都很难。但看着一个人真正尝试去做一件事、去通过一项法案，你就会发现国会功能失调的本质在某些方面发生了变化，而这些变化与唐纳德·特朗普有着非常具体的联系。
And OK, yes, we take for granted right now how messed up Congress is. We don't even think twice about that. But for this hour, I would just ask you to open your mind and heart to the idea that there is another way this could have gone with DACA.
好吧，是的，我们现在已经习惯了国会是多么糟糕。我们甚至对此习以为常。但在这一个小时里，我只是请求你敞开胸怀，去思考一下，DACA本可能有另一种结局。
And arguably, it should have gone if our democracy was working like we read about in high school, that when a vast majority in a democracy want something, it happens. For Jeff Flake, after those four months were done-- after playing the game the way everybody else does, which you'll hear him do at the beginning of the story-- politicking and horsetrading votes.
可以说，如果我们的民主制度如我们在高中读到的那样运作，即当民主社会中的绝大多数人想要某件事时，它就会发生，那么DACA本应通过。对于杰夫·弗莱克来说，在那四个月结束后——在像其他人一样玩弄政治，进行讨价还价之后（你会在故事开头听到他这样做）。
After all that, even he comes to see differently how Congress should operate. So that's our show today. It'll be in four acts which correspond roughly to the four at bats Senator Flake gets to push DACA forward. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
经历这一切后，连他自己都对国会应如何运作有了不同的看法。这就是我们今天的节目。节目分为四幕，大致对应参议员弗莱克为推动DACA而进行的四次尝试。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
So if you remember, back in September, President Trump ended President Obama's DACA program, leaving Dreamers in limbo with the threat of eventual deportation. And he gave Congress six months to pass a bill, six months to fix things for the Dreamers.
如果你还记得，去年九月，特朗普总统终止了奥巴马总统的DACA项目，使“梦想生”们陷入了最终可能被驱逐出境的担忧中。他给了国会六个月的时间来通过法案，六个月的时间来为“梦想生”们解决问题。
The deadline was March 5. The clock started ticking. That's how long Jeff Flake has to get this done. And let's just jump right in with Act One-- Act One, The Bluff. And we're going to start at the first place that Jeff Flake can try to exercise his leverage and his new-found bulletproof superpower.
截止日期是3月5日。倒计时已经开始。这就是杰夫·弗莱克完成这项任务的剩余时间。让我们直接进入第一幕——第一幕，虚张声势。我们将从杰夫·弗莱克可以尝试行使他的筹码和他新获得的“刀枪不入”的超能力的地方开始。
And that is December. It's late December, when Congress is all about trying to pass their tax cuts. You might remember this. They wanted to give the president a big victory before the end of the year. They wanted to prove that a Republican House and Senate and White House could work together to actually get things done.
那就是十二月。那时是十二月下旬，国会的所有精力都集中在试图通过税改方案上。你可能还记得这一点。他们想在年底前给总统送上一场大胜利。他们想证明共和党控制的众议院、参议院和白宫可以通力合作，真正把事情办成。
The date is December 19. Zoe Chace takes it from here.
日期是12月19日。接下来的报道由佐伊·蔡斯负责。
We zoom in on Flake's Senate office in the Russell Building. Because the Republicans are so desperate for a win and because Majority Leader Mitch McConnell needs every vote he can get, no Democrats will vote for the tax cuts.
我们将镜头拉近到弗莱克在罗素大楼的参议院办公室。因为共和党人非常渴望胜利，而且因为多数党领袖米奇·麦康奈尔（Mitch McConnell）需要每一张选票，所以没有民主党人会投票支持税改。
This is Flake's moment that he was counting on. It's an opportunity to use the leverage he has to move DACA ahead. He and Chuck Schumer, the Democratic leader, cook up a plan. He proposes a trade to Mitch McConnell-- my vote for the tax bill in exchange for a promise to get a DACA bill on the floor by the end of January. And now they are just about to vote.
这就是弗莱克所指望的时刻。这是一个利用他手中的筹码来推进DACA的机会。他和民主党领袖查克·舒默（Chuck Schumer）策划了一个方案。他向米奇·麦康奈尔提议进行交易——我投票支持税改法案，作为交换，你承诺在1月底前将DACA法案提交到参议院讨论。现在，他们马上就要投票了。
You're the last holdout on this tax bill.
你是这个税改法案的最后一个钉子户。
Am I?
是吗？
Are you undecided on how you're going to vote on that?
你还没决定怎么投票吗？
I mean, if you're negotiating for something outside of the bill, you never indicate where you'll be for certain. Never say what you're going to do. [CHUCKLES].
我是说，如果你在法案之外进行谈判，你永远不会明确表示你会站在哪一边。永远不要说你要做什么。[轻笑]。
This is a bluff. Flake loves the tax bill. He loves tax cuts. He knows he's going to vote for the bill even if he doesn't get what he wants. Eventually, he tells me that. But he doesn't tell anybody else.
这是一种虚张声势。弗莱克喜欢税改法案。他喜欢减税。他知道即使没有得到他想要的东西，他最终还是会投赞成票。后来，他告诉了我这一点。但他没有告诉其他人。
We hop onto the Senate subway. And another reporter tries to get it out of him.
我们跳上参议院的地铁。另一名记者试图从他嘴里打听消息。
Have you made up your mind on the--
你决定好了吗？关于……
I'm still working.
我还在努力。
--tax vote.
……关于税改投票。
I'm still working on the DACA issue.
我还在为DACA的问题努力。
The funny thing is the tax bill can pass without him. They think they have the 50 votes they need already. If you're some kind of Congress nerd and you're counting, Doug Jones hasn't been seated yet. John McCain is out on medical.
有趣的是，税改法案没有他也能通过。他们认为他们已经有了所需的50票。如果你是一个计票的国会迷，你会发现道格·琼斯还没就职。约翰·麦凯恩因病缺席。
But who knows? They just got the 50. Bob Corker, Republican from Tennessee, he recently came around for no apparent reason. With things in flux like this, maybe someone could flip. And then Flake would have a lot more leverage.
但谁知道呢？他们刚刚凑齐了50票。来自田纳西州的共和党人鲍勃·科克（Bob Corker）最近莫名其妙地倒戈了。在局势如此变动的情况下，也许有人会反水。那样弗莱克就会有更多筹码。
And Flake's been working on a DACA bill with other Republicans and Democrats, a bipartisan bill. And he wants that bill to get a vote.
而且弗莱克一直在与其他共和党人和民主党人合作起草一份DACA法案，这是一份两党法案。他希望该法案能进行投票。
Bring it to the floor. Agree to bring it to the floor. Use me as an excuse. Say we've got to get Flake. So we had to agree to DACA. That's done a lot. I mean, you've--
把它提交到议会。同意把它提交上来。把我当作借口。就说我们要争取弗莱克，所以必须同意DACA。这已经做了很多了。我是说，你已经……
How do I describe Jeff Flake? Suit and tie, clasped hands, earnestly looking at me on his office couch. I mean, he's a senator. He's deeply earnest to the point where he's kind of dorky.
我该如何形容杰夫·弗莱克？西装革履，双手合十，在办公室沙发上认真地看着我。我是说，他是一位参议员。他非常认真，认真到有点书呆子气。
He's a Mormon. He's super disciplined. He often goes to the gym twice a day. He has this way of being more hopeful than it seems like he should. When it comes to Mitch McConnell, the leader of the Senate, Flake often seems like Charlie Brown running to kick the football to McConnell's Lucy.
他是摩门教徒。他极其自律。他经常一天去两次健身房。他有一种比看起来更乐观的方式。谈到参议院领袖米奇·麦康奈尔时，弗莱克看起来就像查理·布朗（Charlie Brown），正奔向去踢麦康奈尔那块“露西（Lucy）”式的足球。
But right now, he feels like the power dynamic has changed. Jeff Flake is suited up. He feels like he has some moves. About immigration, when Flake talks about it, he often talks about economics. We're an aging country. We need workers. He has a libertarian mindset about it.
但此刻，他觉得权力动态已经改变了。杰夫·弗莱克整装待发。他觉得自己有几招。谈到移民时，弗莱克经常谈论经济。我们是一个老龄化国家。我们需要工人。他在这个问题上有自由意志主义者的思维。
The economics are personal to him, though. He grew up on a cattle ranch in northern Arizona. His dad hired undocumented immigrants. And he got to know them. And he liked them. He writes about one of them in his book, this guy he grew up with, Manuel.
不过，经济问题对他个人来说是有感情色彩的。他在亚利桑那州北部的一个牛场长大。他父亲雇佣了无证移民。他了解他们。他喜欢他们。他在书中写到了其中一个人，那个和他一起长大的家伙，曼努埃尔（Manuel）。
It's in that kind of tokenizing style that politicians can use when they write about real life people caught up in national policy. But I've spent enough time with him to know that his feelings on immigration-- they are sincere, they are deeply held, and they are different from a lot of his colleagues. So Manuel.
这是一种政治人物在撰写涉及国家政策的现实生活人物时经常使用的“代币化”风格。但我花了很多时间和弗莱克在一起，我知道他对移民的感觉——那是真诚的，深埋于心的，并且与他的许多同事不同。所以，曼努埃尔。
Manuel came when I was just very young. And he was young himself. He was 16. And we thought he was old and wise. And he worked in the shop mostly on the farm and would fix just anything that broke. And baling wire, duct tape-- some of it wasn't pretty. He was never much of a welder. But he--
曼努埃尔在我很小的时候就来了。他自己也很年轻。他才16岁。我们觉得他老练而有智慧。他在农场里的大部分时间都在修理车间，几乎能修理任何坏掉的东西。铁丝、胶带——有些修理得并不美观。他不太会焊接。但他……
Flake worked all summer on the ranch, too. He says he was always breaking the equipment. So he ended up hanging out a lot with Manuel, talking about his girlfriend.
弗莱克整个暑假也在农场工作。他说他总是弄坏设备。所以他最后花了很多时间和曼努埃尔待在一起，聊他的女朋友。
One conversation that we still laugh about-- he's asking if I was dating anybody else. I said, no, no, just Cheryl. And he said-- his English by this time was pretty good. But some of the phrases were a little off.
我们至今还会笑着谈起的一段对话——他问我有没有和别人约会。我说没有，没有，只有谢丽尔（Cheryl）。他说——他那时候英语已经相当好了。但有些短语用得有点怪。
He said, Jeff, you know the saying. He said, when the cat is gone, the mouse, he can run around. [LAUGHS] And--
他说，杰夫，你知道那句话。他说，猫不在家，耗子就跳梁。[笑声] 而且……
Flake was on Manuel's side. When the border patrol would come and do these roundups, Flake would pull his hat down low over his head and ride his horse in the opposite direction of where the workers were, trying to lure the Cessnas away.
弗莱克站在曼努埃尔这一边。当边境巡逻队来搜捕时，弗莱克会把帽子压得很低，骑着马往工人们逃离的相反方向跑，试图把直升机引开。
He just saw Manuel at his dad's funeral last year. Manuel's got a green card now, seven kids. One's adopted. A merit-based system, he says, like the president has called for-- it wouldn't account for all these guys I've known who made their lives here, made the country better. That's how he sees it.
他去年在他父亲的葬礼上又见到了曼努埃尔。曼努埃尔现在有了绿卡，有七个孩子。其中一个是被领养的。他说，像总统所呼吁的那样，建立一个基于能力的体制，根本无法照顾到我认识的这些在这里生活、让国家变得更好的家伙。这就是他的看法。
Flake's worked on immigration bills practically every year-- 2003, 2004, 2005, 2006. He was part of the Gang of Eight that tried to do comprehensive immigration reform in 2013. DACA is the bare minimum of what he would do if he could. He'd love to make it much easier for more people to work and live here. But there's no place in his party for that idea anymore.
弗莱克几乎每年都在参与移民法案的工作——2003年、2004年、2005年、2006年。他是2013年试图进行全面移民改革的“八人帮”成员之一。如果可以的话，DACA是他能接受的最低限度。他很乐意让更多人更容易地在这里工作和生活。但现在他的党内已经没有这种想法的容身之地了。
DACA, though, DACA is different. Most people like DACA. As we rush Aaron Sorkin-style through the Dirksen Building, he explains how he gets even more leverage if another Republican peels off. That's what he's waiting for. And the most likely person that could be right now hours before the tax vote is Senator Susan Collins.
不过，DACA有所不同。大多数人喜欢DACA。当我们像艾伦·索金（Aaron Sorkin）风格的剧中人物那样匆忙穿过德克森大楼时，他解释说，如果有另一名共和党人倒戈，他将如何获得更多筹码。这就是他正在等待的。而在税改投票前几个小时，目前最有可能的人选是苏珊·柯林斯（Susan Collins）参议员。
And she called me this morning. And she has some issues.
她今天早上给我打了电话。她有一些疑虑。
Collins has her own deal also unrelated to the tax bill, that she's trying to use her tax bill vote to get leverage on. She wants some stuff to patch up Obamacare. And she's been threatening to vote against the tax bill if that isn't addressed. Yesterday, Majority Leader Mitch McConnell went on the Senate floor and promised to address her issues. But Flake says Collins' situation is still a little shaky.
柯林斯也有她自己的交易，与税改法案无关，她试图利用她在税改法案上的投票权来获取筹码。她想要一些东西来修补奥巴马医改（Obamacare）。如果这些问题得不到解决，她一直威胁要投票反对税改法案。昨天，多数党领袖米奇·麦康奈尔在参议院楼层承诺会解决她的问题。但弗莱克说柯林斯的处境仍然有点摇摆不定。
She had a long meeting with the vice president today. So she's close. But it's still working on a few things.
她今天和副总统开了一个长会。所以她很接近了。但还在处理一些事情。
That's good for you, huh?
这对你来说是好事，对吧？
But--
但是……
But she's not going to necessarily pull what you're pulling. She's pulling for something else.
但她不一定会采取你采取的行动。她在争取别的东西。
Right. She pulling for something else. But we both-- it works out.
没错。她在争取别的东西。但我们双方——这最终会解决的。
He ducks into a Senate Judiciary Committee hearing. Meanwhile, calls are flooding into his office. You're a Republican. Support the president's tax bill. Have a spine. Vote against the president's tax bill.
他闪身进入了一个参议院司法委员会的听证会。与此同时，电话涌入他的办公室。你是个共和党人。支持总统的税改法案。硬气点。投票反对总统的税改法案。
When I catch up with Flake that night, he still hasn't heard from McConnell. To be clear, what Flake is trying to get is modest. He's not trying to get an actual DACA deal done or a formal announcement. He just wants a sort of pinky swear from the Majority Leader.
那天晚上我追上弗莱克时，他还是没有得到麦康奈尔的回应。明确地说，弗莱克想要得到的只是微不足道的东西。他并不是试图真正达成一项DACA协议或获得正式公告。他只是想要多数党领袖的一个“拉钩”承诺。
The Majority Leader will not make any public promises about DACA right now. Flake believes that's because he's scared. It'll make Republicans in the House flip out and endanger the tax cut bill. OK, fair enough. He can work with that.
多数党领袖现在不会对DACA做出任何公开承诺。弗莱克认为这是因为他害怕。这会让众议院的共和党人发疯，危及税改法案。好吧，有道理。他可以处理。
But notice just how hard it is to get this simple thing done. Flake heads off to talk to McConnell to try to get his firm commitment. And he leaves me behind in his office where I suffer two off-the-record hours with his Chief of Staff Chandler Morse, one office over from Flake's. We talk a lot.
但请注意，完成这件简单的事情有多难。弗莱克动身去和麦康奈尔谈，试图获得他的坚定承诺。他把我留在他的办公室里，我和他的幕僚长钱德勒·莫尔斯（Chandler Morse）在弗莱克办公室隔壁，度过了不予录音的两个小时。我们聊了很多。
What did you think was going to happen?
你觉得会发生什么？
Chandler is a character I wish I could tell you more about. I'm allowed to reveal the following things from those hours. Between calls and emails, he ate a seven-day-old, seven-layer bean and salsa dip. Then he ate a Popsicle. He texts and emails like his life depends on it.
钱德勒是我希望多跟你说说的人物。在这几个小时里，我被允许透露以下内容。在处理电话和邮件之余，他吃了一份放了七天、有七层的豆子莎莎酱。然后他吃了一根冰棒。他发短信和邮件的样子，就像他的生命取决于此。
At 10 o'clock that night, Flake shows back up with news.
那天晚上10点，弗莱克带着消息回来了。
Now what?
现在怎么样？
We hustle into his office. And he runs me through the story of the two hours that just happened.
我们匆忙走进他的办公室。他向我讲述了刚才那两个小时发生的事情。
So right-- so you left here, you went to go talk to the Majority Leader.
所以——你离开这里后，去和多数党领袖谈话了。
Well, he was over in the Mansfield Room. We're all eating dinner, and I sat down. And he said, you OK on this? I said, no, no. I said, I need to know if we have a commitment to bring this bill up in January because that was what we were talking about before.
嗯，他在曼斯菲尔德厅。我们都在吃晚饭，我坐下来。他说，这件事你没问题吧？我说，不，不。我说，我需要知道我们是否有承诺在1月提出这个法案，因为那是我们之前谈的内容。
To bring up the DACA bill.
提出DACA法案。
And he said, I can't. I can't commit. I don't want to commit to something that I can't deliver on. And the spending bill is now kicked into January. And I just can't.
他说，我不能。我不能承诺。我不想承诺我无法兑现的事情。支出法案现在被推迟到了1月。我实在不能。
Oh, no.
哦，不。
And so I said, well, you couldn't do it in December. And I understood that. But January, even if there's a spending bill, we have to do on the 17th, that still leaves quite a bit, a month. No, I can't do it. Can't commit. And so I just walked away.
所以我说，好吧，你十二月做不到。我理解。但一月，即使有支出法案，我们在17号还得做，那还剩下不少时间，一个月。他说，不，我不能。不能承诺。所以我只好走开了。
Then later he came back over a bit and just said, I hope you understand. I just can't commit. I never commit to bring bills up.
后来他又回来了一点，只是说，希望你理解。我真的不能承诺。我从来不承诺提交法案。
McConnell doesn't like immigration. Flake thinks he thinks it's generally a losing issue for their party. Plus McConnell has the votes without Flake. And anyway, I'm guessing he sees through the bluff and knows Flake is going to vote for the tax bill no matter what.
麦康奈尔不喜欢移民问题。弗莱克认为他觉得这对他们的政党来说通常是个赔本买卖。再说，麦康奈尔没有弗莱克的票也能赢。不管怎样，我猜他看穿了弗莱克的虚张声势，知道无论如何他都会投票支持税改法案。
Jeff Flake isn't a sulker, exactly. But it's hard to imagine what else he could have been doing over dinner while Chandler was upstairs, chewing on a popsicle stick and texting him. He was out of moves. But then, after McConnell left, the vice president called him, Mike Pence. And Flake gets back a sliver of leverage.
杰夫·弗莱克算不上闷闷不乐，但他很难想象，当钱德勒在楼上嚼着冰棒棍给他发短信时，他自己在晚饭时还能做些什么。他没招了。但后来，麦康奈尔离开后，副总统迈克·彭斯（Mike Pence）给他打了电话。弗莱克又得到了一丝筹码。
For Pence, they don't want any Republican voting against this bill.
对于彭斯来说，他们不希望有任何共和党人投票反对这个法案。
They just want it to look pretty.
他们只是想让场面好看。
I mean, obviously.
我是说，很明显。
The White House wants every Republican on board for the tax vote. It'll look good that way, a united front. Pence and Flake go way back. They were famously tight when they were both in the house. They've been strained lately.
白宫希望每一位共和党人都支持税改投票。那样看起来会很好，一个团结的阵线。彭斯和弗莱克交情深厚。他们都在众议院时，关系好是出了名的。最近他们的关系有些紧张。
This has caused Flake a little anguish. They don't agree on the president. There's always a pretty intense wistfulness mixed with defensiveness when Flake talks about Pence. And he talks about him a lot actually because that's his only big connection to the White House.
这让弗莱克感到一丝痛苦。他们在总统的问题上意见不一。弗莱克谈到彭斯时，总是混杂着一种强烈的怀旧和防御心理。事实上，他经常谈论他，因为那是他与白宫唯一的重大联系。
Their long friendship was forged when they both stood up to President Bush over No Child Left Behind and then again over his prescription drug plan. They both love tax cuts. They both hate spending. Anyway, he's a bit tortured that he and Pence are on different sides now.
他们的长期友谊是在他们两人共同抵制布什总统的“不让一个孩子掉队（No Child Left Behind）”法案时建立的，后来又在处方药计划上再次并肩作战。他们都喜欢减税。他们都讨厌开支。无论如何，他和彭斯现在站在对立面，这让他感到有些折磨。
And Pence, he and I are close. We talk about tax cuts. And we've been working on this stuff for a long time. This has been-- best friends in the House. I think it's been a personal kind of thing for him. And I understand that.
我和彭斯关系很近。我们谈论减税。我们在这个问题上已经合作了很长时间。这曾经是——我们在众议院时是最好的朋友。我想这对他来说是一件私人的事情。我理解。
We always stuck together back then. We like to stick together when we can. And I think he saw it as his personal mission kind of, too. So he gave me all kinds of good reasons. Frankly, to vote for the bill, I didn't need to hear them. But Mike, you know, he's a good friend. But I've made no commitment after that call.
那时我们总是团结在一起。我们喜欢在能团结的时候团结在一起。我想他也把这当作他个人的使命。所以他给了我各种各样的好理由。坦率地说，为了投票支持该法案，我不需要听到这些。但迈克，你知道，他是个好朋友。但在那次通话后我没有做出任何承诺。
Remember, he is actually voting for the bill but not letting on to his buddy Mike. This bill that, under different circumstances, they would be celebrating together. Also there's a good chance Pence knows Flake's bluffing. So they're kind of playacting with each other.
记住，他实际上会投票支持该法案，但没有告诉他的朋友迈克。这份法案，在不同情况下，他们本会一起庆祝。另外，彭斯很有可能知道弗莱克在虚张声势。所以他们某种程度上是在相互演戏。
I mean, did it feel bad?
我是说，感觉不好吗？
Yeah, well, and I mean, yeah. Mike said, well, we're going to get this done. The president's committed. I'm committed. Paul's committed in the House.
是的，嗯，我是说，是的。迈克说，好吧，我们会完成这件事。总统承诺了。我承诺了。保罗在众议院也承诺了。
Paul Ryan, Speaker of the House-- Pence is saying they'll do it, DACA. Everybody wants to do DACA. But they're not going to publicly commit to doing it right now.
保罗·瑞安（Paul Ryan），众议院议长——彭斯在说他们会做的，关于DACA。每个人都想做DACA。但他们现在不会公开承诺要做。
The Senate, they know they've got to get it done. It will get done. Your name is going to be all over it, whatever else. I said, if they'll get it done, I'll step back, take my name off of all of it, and just vote for it. Just get it done. I just want to get this done.
参议院，他们知道他们必须完成它。它会完成的。无论如何，你的名字都会写在上面。我说，如果他们能完成，我会退后，把我的名字从这一切中去掉，只投票支持它。只要完成它就行。我只想完成这件事。
And he said, no, I know. I know. Just know that we're going to get it done with no commitment.
他说，不，我知道。我知道。只要知道我们会完成它就好，没有任何承诺。
As Flake's recounting all this to me late night in his office, we're interrupted by a phone call.
当弗莱克在办公室深夜向我讲述这一切时，我们被一个电话打断了。
Weren't there just points today where you were like, I should just say, yes.
今天没有那些时刻让你觉得，我应该直接说，好的。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Oh, go ahead.
哦，请便。
Hello.
喂。
It's Lindsey Graham. Lindsey Graham is Flake's Republican partner in crime on the DACA bill. He's kind of the Ernie to Flake's Bert, wisecracking where Flake is earnest and shy. It turns out there was a final dramatic scene that happened just before Flake came back to talk to me, that he was about to tell me before Lindsey Graham called. But now I get to hear him tell it to Graham on the phone.
是林赛·格雷厄姆（Lindsey Graham）。林赛·格雷厄姆是弗莱克在DACA法案上的共和党犯罪合伙人。他有点像弗莱克的“厄尼（Ernie）”对应“伯特（Bert）”，当弗莱克认真且害羞时，他则是那个妙语连珠的人。事实证明，在弗莱克回来和我谈话之前，发生了一个最终的戏剧性场景，他本想在我接电话前告诉我，但现在我能听到他在电话里告诉格雷厄姆。
Hey, you know what happened?
嘿，你知道发生了什么吗？
So after dinner, in the Mansfield room, in the long call with Mike Pence--
晚饭后，在曼斯菲尔德厅，在与迈克·彭斯的长谈中——
Mitch called me.
米奇打电话给我了。
What did he say?
他说了什么？
He gave a commitment. Firm.
他给出了承诺。坚定的。
Did he?
真的吗？
Yeah. You got that right.
是的。你说对了。
In a surprising twist, not long after Flake hung up with Mike Pence, Mitch McConnell called his phone and abruptly reversed himself. "I don't usually do this," McConnell said to Flake, "But--" And he went on to give Flake what he wanted. He committed to bring DACA to the Senate floor in January for a vote.
在一个令人惊讶的转折中，弗莱克与迈克·彭斯挂断电话后不久，米奇·麦康奈尔给他打了电话，突然反悔了。“我通常不这么做，”麦康奈尔对弗莱克说，“但是——”他接着给了弗莱克想要的东西。他承诺在1月份将DACA提交到参议院进行投票。
The bluff worked. Even if McConnell saw through it to begin with, he decided he had to be sure of him. Flake got his DACA vote promise. And it happens, Flake learned, because of what happened with Susan Collins.
虚张声势奏效了。即使麦康奈尔一开始就看穿了它，他也决定必须确定他的立场。弗莱克得到了DACA投票的承诺。而据弗莱克所知，这之所以发生，是因为苏珊·柯林斯发生的事情。
She called me while I was on the phone with Mitch.
我在和米奇通话时，她给我打了电话。
Flake was on the phone with Mitch McConnell when Susan Collins beeped in. He put Mitch on hold, clicked over, said hi to Susan, told her to hang on a second.
弗莱克在和米奇·麦康奈尔通电话时，苏珊·柯林斯拨了进来。他把米奇置于保留状态，点击切换，向苏珊问好，让她等一会儿。
I just put her on hold while I finished the call with Mitch.
我只是让她等着，同时完成了和米奇的通话。
He clicked back over to McConnell. He wanted to make sure he got his commitment. He got it. Then he hung up with McConnell and got back on with Collins.
他点击回麦康奈尔。他想确保得到承诺。他得到了。然后他挂断了麦康奈尔的电话，又和柯林斯通了话。
And then learned that the deal with her had gone south.
然后得知与她的交易已经破裂。
She was calling Flake to let him know her deal with McConnell had changed and see where he was at. And where he was at was psyched because he, just moments ago, gotten what he wanted.
她是打电话给弗莱克，让他知道她与麦康奈尔的交易已经改变，看看他的立场在哪里。而他的立场是狂喜，因为就在几分钟前，他得到了他想要的东西。
"This is good news," I can hear Graham crowing on the other end of the phone.
“这可是个好消息，”我能听到格雷厄姆在电话那头欢呼。
But anyway, we got the commitment. By the end of January, they're going to bring up our bill. We've just got to finish. We've just got to finish it.
但无论如何，我们得到了承诺。到1月底，他们会提交我们的法案。我们只需要完成它。我们只需要完成它。
"That made my night!" Graham yells.
“那让我的夜晚圆满了！”格雷厄姆喊道。
OK.
好的。
They hang up.
他们挂了电话。
Bye.
再见。
And then almost immediately, his phone rings again.
然后几乎立刻，他的电话又响了。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
It's Vice President Mike Pence. Flake tells me to stop recording.
是副总统迈克·彭斯。弗莱克让我停止录音。
OK.
好的。
I later piece together how this all went down and learn just how convoluted the backstage maneuvering was that night that finally got Jeff Flake what he wanted. Leverage wasn't enough. He also got lucky.
后来我拼凑出了这一切是如何发生的，并了解了那天晚上最终让杰夫·弗莱克得到他想要的东西的后台博弈是多么复杂。杠杆作用还不够。他还很幸运。
Mike Pence seems to be the reason that Susan Collins' deal and Flake's deal both changed at the last minute. And their deals changed because of another issue I didn't see coming, abortion. Susan Collins wanted that Obamacare fix.
迈克·彭斯似乎是苏珊·柯林斯的交易和弗莱克的交易都在最后一刻发生变化的原因。而他们的交易发生变化是因为另一个我没预料到的问题，堕胎。苏珊·柯林斯想要那个奥巴马医改修复方案。
At the eleventh hour, these antiabortion activists met up with Mike Pence because they heard about Susan Collins' Obamacare fix. They thought it would result in federal dollars going towards abortions. They did not like that.
在最后一刻，这些反堕胎激进分子遇到了迈克·彭斯，因为他们听说了苏珊·柯林斯的奥巴马医改修复计划。他们认为这将导致联邦资金流向堕胎。他们不喜欢那样。
Mike Pence is passionately, vigorously against abortion. That is his big issue. Pence then met with Collins. As best I can tell, this meeting changed things for Collins' deal. And she was unhappy about it. And in fact, the provision she wanted did get kicked down the road.
迈克·彭斯极其强烈地反对堕胎。这是他的重大问题。彭斯随后会见了柯林斯。据我所知，这次会面改变了柯林斯的交易。她对此感到不悦。事实上，她想要的条款确实被推迟了。
After all that, McConnell's office wanted to be absolutely certain of every Republican vote because they'd been burned by a defection just three weeks before. So McConnell made a game-time decision to call Flake and give him what he wanted with DACA.
经历这一切后，麦康奈尔的办公室想要绝对确定每一张共和党选票，因为他们三周前刚被一次倒戈烧伤过。所以麦康奈尔在比赛关键时刻做出了决定，打电话给弗莱克，给了他想要的DACA承诺。
The Sergeant at Arms will restore order in the gallery.
警卫官会恢复画廊的秩序。
And later that night, when the tax bill comes to the floor--
后来那天晚上，当税改法案提交到议会时——
Senators voting in the affirmative-- Alexander, Barrasso, Blunt--
投赞成票的参议员——亚历山大、巴拉索、布朗特……
Collins votes for it.
柯林斯投票赞成。
--Collins, Corker--
……柯林斯、科克……
She votes for it even though she apparently got shivved at the last second.
她投票赞成，尽管她显然在最后一秒被捅了一刀。
--Daines, Enzi, Ernst, Fischer, Flake, Gardner, Graham, Grassley, Hatch, Heller, Hoeven, Inhofe, Isakson, Johnson--
……戴恩斯、恩齐、恩斯特、费舍尔、弗莱克、加德纳、格雷厄姆、格拉斯利、哈奇、海勒、霍文、英霍夫、伊萨克森、约翰逊……
Act Two, Flake's Second at Bat-- Now with the President. It's weird to be inside a senator's office, listening to him gossip with other lawmakers like a kid on the phone and then see that gossip become news and then government business.
第二幕，弗莱克的第二次尝试——现在是与总统的。走进参议员的办公室，听他和议员们像电话里的孩子一样聊八卦，然后看到这些八卦变成了新闻，最后变成了政府事务，这真是太怪了。
A commitment on a cell phone between two guys seeps out through the halls of the Capitol and onto cable TV.
两个男人在手机上的承诺，通过国会大厦的走廊渗透到有线电视上。
The lawmakers are negotiating a bill impacting undocumented immigrants.
议员们正在协商一项影响无证移民的法案。
Immigration, specifically DACA.
移民，特别是DACA。
Really, DACA is at the center of everything.
真的，DACA是所有事物的中心。
And keep in mind, Senator Jeff Flake is expecting a DACA bill signed in the new year.
请记住，杰夫·弗莱克参议员预计新的一年会有DACA法案签署。
McConnell gives a press conference on December 22, a few days after the tax bill passes.
麦康奈尔在12月22日，即税改法案通过几天后举行了新闻发布会。
We have a commitment on a bipartisan basis to address the DACA issue. And there's a working group. And I've said to them, if they can come up with an agreement that the administration is comfortable with, will devote floor time to that in January as well.
我们已经承诺以两党为基础来解决DACA问题。有一个工作组。我告诉他们，如果他们能拿出行政部门感到舒适的协议，我们也会在1月份为该协议提供会议时间。
Pay attention to that phrase.
注意那个短语。
--an agreement that the administration is comfortable with--
……一个行政部门感到舒适的协议……
Sounds as monotonous as the rest, totally standard. Just keep it in mind because that is not the deal Flake thinks he got. Anyway, now that Flake has dealt with McConnell, he has to get the White House on board.
听起来像其他部分一样单调，完全标准。只要记住这一点，因为那不是弗莱克认为他得到的协议。无论如何，既然弗莱克已经和麦康奈尔打过交道，他必须让白宫参与进来。
Up till now, it's been relatively normal political horse trading. Now all that's going to change. It's not an easy thing for Flake to do to ask Trump to work with him. Trump and Flake do not get along in a very loud and public way.
到目前为止，这相对正常的政治讨价还价。现在这一切都要变了。弗莱克要求特朗普与他合作并非易事。特朗普和弗莱克以一种非常响亮和公开的方式合不来。
Like recently, Trump went to Arizona and trash talked both Republican senators, first John McCain and then--
比如最近，特朗普去了亚利桑那州，痛骂了两位共和党参议员，先是约翰·麦凯恩，然后是……
And nobody wants me to talk about your other senator, who's weak on borders, weak on crime. So I won't talk about him.
没人想让我谈论你们的另一位参议员，他在边境问题上软弱，在犯罪问题上软弱。所以我不会谈论他。
[BOOING]
[嘘声]
Nobody wants me to talk about him. Nobody knows who the hell he is.
没人想让我谈论他。没人知道这人是谁。
Here's a question. Have you talked to the president? Has he called you or anything?
这里有个问题。你和总统谈过吗？他给你打过电话之类的吗？
I was at the White House on the NAFTA issue.
我在白宫谈过NAFTA问题。
I saw you on TV sitting next to him.
我在电视上看到你坐在他旁边。
That hostage looking photo, I guess. That's--
那张看起来像人质的照片，我想。那是……
You didn't look relaxed.
你看起来不放松。
In this photo, his lips are pressed together. He looks like he's sitting as far apart from the president as he can get. One of the NAFTA renegotiation meetings-- Flake's a NAFTA fan. Trump calls it the worst trade deal ever made.
在这张照片中，他的嘴唇紧闭。他看起来坐得离总统越远越好。NAFTA重新谈判会议之一——弗莱克是NAFTA的粉丝。特朗普称其为有史以来最糟糕的贸易协定。
As soon as I walked in that room, I thought, I'm going to be next to him, aren't I? Yep. But he did pull me aside and said that he had spoken to Mike Pence and others and that he expressed again his desire to move ahead on DACA. He said, we're going to get this done.
我一走进那个房间，就想，我得在他旁边，不是吗？没错。但他确实把我拉到一边，说他已经和迈克·彭斯等人谈过了，并且再次表达了他推进DACA的愿望。他说，我们会完成这件事。
This conversation weeks ago remains a North Star for Flake. The president said, we're going to get this done. So we're going to get it done. He believes that. He understands that what the White House wants for DACA is the wall.
几周前的这次谈话仍然是弗莱克的北极星。总统说，我们会完成这件事。所以我们要完成它。他相信这一点。他理解白宫想要DACA作为换取隔离墙的筹码。
And for a while the main question is what's a wall. How expensive? How many miles? In December, the White House finally gets specific. It's going to be $2 billion worth of wall this next year along with other border security stuff. Flake is like, great. We're moving forward.
而一段时间以来，主要的问题是什么是隔离墙。多贵？多少英里？十二月，白宫最终明确了。明年将有价值20亿美元的隔离墙以及其他边境安全事务。弗莱克想，太棒了。我们在前进。
And then just after the New Year, the loop de loop begins. The White House is like, surprise, and drops this list on them. It's the hardest of hard-line immigration policy dream wish list.
然后就在新年刚过，过山车开始了。白宫像是在说，惊喜，并向他们抛出了这份清单。这是最强硬的强硬派移民政策愿望清单。
The White House threw the kitchen sink in and just all of it. Let's do a sign on policy, sanctuary cities. Let's do everything. Let's fund the wall, the whole thing. Let's put that in there.
白宫把一切都扔了进来。让我们做一个准入政策，庇护城市。让我们做所有事情。让我们资助隔离墙，整个事情。让我们把它放进去。
This is not what Flake thought this bill was going to be. Honestly, it surprised me, too. Given what the White House had been saying, it was an abrupt right turn. To get any deal in the Senate, Flake knows it'll need Democrats and Republicans both. And now the Democrats are mad.
这不是弗莱克认为这个法案会成为的样子。坦率地说，我也感到惊讶。鉴于白宫一直在说的话，这是一个突然的右转。要在参议院达成任何协议，弗莱克知道这将需要民主党人和共和党人双方。现在民主党人很生气。
Democrats are slamming the administration's plan for a border wall including Senator Dick Durbin, who said--
民主党人正在抨击政府的边境墙计划，包括迪克·德宾（Dick Durbin）参议员，他说……
Dick Durbin's like, you're piling all these draconian immigration enforcement measures on the backs of Dreamers. That's not what we've been negotiating. Trump's like, maybe the government needs a good shutdown if you're so mad. The Democrats are like, yeah, maybe it does.
迪克·德宾说，你们把所有这些严苛的移民执法措施堆在“梦想生”身上。那不是我们一直在谈判的内容。特朗普说，如果你们这么生气，也许政府需要一次好的停摆。民主党人说，是的，也许确实如此。
That brings us to January 9, a big meeting between the White House and lawmakers. It's the first with Democrats. So it's a big deal. It's supposed to get everyone on the same page. Smooth out all the misunderstandings so they can make this happen.
这把我们带到了1月9日，白宫和立法者之间的一次大型会议。这是第一次有民主党人参加。所以这是一件大事。它本应让每个人都在同一页面上。消除所有误解，以便他们能让这件事发生。
But as is routine for this White House, there are some distractions. As you may remember, the Michael Wolff book, Fire and Fury, has just come out.
但正如这个白宫的惯例一样，有一些干扰。正如你可能记得的那样，迈克尔·沃尔夫（Michael Wolff）的书《火与怒（Fire and Fury）》刚刚出版。
Richard, isn't it remarkable that we're talking about the president's mental state?
理查德（Richard），我们正在谈论总统的精神状态，这难道不引人注目吗？
People are openly questioning the president's sanity on every TV in the Capitol.
人们在国会大厦的每一台电视上公开质疑总统的理智。
This is not mentally stable behavior.
这不是心理稳定行为。
100% of the people closest to the president believe that there is something wrong here.
100%最接近总统的人相信这里有什么不对劲。
There's also news of potential military strikes against North Korea this morning. Reporters catch Flake in the Dirksen hallway.
今天早上还有潜在的针对朝鲜的军事打击新闻。记者们在德克森大厅抓住了弗莱克。
Senator Flake, on a separate foreign policy note, there's a report today that the administration is considering what they're calling nose--
弗莱克参议员，关于另一个外交政策事项，今天有一份报告称，政府正在考虑他们所谓的鼻子……
A bloody nose?
流鼻血？
Bloody nose strategy in North Korea, where they would strategically strike several sites. Have you seen those reports?
朝鲜的流鼻血策略，他们会战略性地打击几个地点。你看到那些报告了吗？
No, I have not. I have not. I have to look at it first.
没有，我没有。我得先看一看。
Hi, Senator Flake. I'm Reyna. I'm a Dreamer. We've met.
你好，弗莱克参议员。我是雷娜（Reyna）。我是一个“梦想生”。我们见过面。
Oh, hi.
哦，你好。
That voice-- that's a woman who comes up to Flake, a DACA recipient named Reyna. This is starting to happen a lot. Everywhere we go in the Capitol, we run into DACA kids. Sometimes it's in big groups in matching orange shirts and orange beanies, yelling, "Dream Act Now."
那个声音——那是一位走近弗莱克的女性，一位名叫雷娜的DACA受益者。这种情况开始频繁发生。我们在国会大厦无论走到哪里，都会遇到DACA的孩子。有时他们成群结队，穿着配套的橙色衬衫和橙色豆豆帽，高喊“现在就通过梦想法案”。
Reyna came here with a small group. She drove 48 hours from Arizona. And she's different from other Dreamers I meet at the Capitol. She's more like a Politico reporter than an advocate. She knows there's a bipartisan bill in the works. She knows that Flake is working on it. She knows there's a meeting today at the White House.
雷娜和一小群人来到这里。她开了48小时的车从亚利桑那州赶来。她和我在此次国会遇到的其他“梦想生”不同。她更像是一个Politico记者，而不是倡导者。她知道有一项两党法案正在酝酿中。她知道弗莱克正在努力工作。她知道今天在白宫有一个会议。
She says, we're just kind of worried to see if you would see something happening in terms of the deal coming closer.
她说，我们只是有点担心，想看看你是否会看到协议在接近达成。
I'm just really kind of worried to see if you would say something happening in terms of the deal that's coming closer.
我们只是有点担心，想看看你是否会说协议在接近达成。
We're going to the White House right now for a bipartisan meeting. And it involves 27 people.
我们现在要去白宫参加一个两党会议。涉及27个人。
That's so many people.
人太多了。
A bipartisan meeting with 27 people. Reyna and Flake worry together that's too many.
27人的两党会议。雷娜和弗莱克都担心人太多了。
Too many. It's not going to be that much negotiation. But we're-- all I can say is we're doing all we can.
太多了。不会有那么多谈判的。但是我们——我只能说我们正在尽我们所能。
Well, thank you so much for your leadership. And we just want to be able to be helpful.
嗯，非常感谢你的领导。我们只是想提供帮助。
All right. Thank you. Nice to meet you.
好的。非常感谢。很高兴认识你。
Nice to meet you.
很高兴认识你。
All right.
好的。
When Reyna talks to senators, she talks strategy. She doesn't tell her story. To be honest, that's the way to talk to Flake, I think. He can seem a little cold when it comes to constituents.
当雷娜和参议员交谈时，她谈论策略。她不讲自己的故事。说实话，我认为这是和弗莱克谈话的方式。当谈到选民时，他看起来有点冷淡。
I rarely hear him talk about what Dreamers want. He talks about what Schumer wants, what McConnell doesn't. Reyna and the other Dreamers are in the weirdest legislative cul-de-sac imaginable. Their issue is immensely popular, which you'd think would be an asset. But in fact, it's a curse.
我很少听到他谈论“梦想生”想要什么。他谈论的是舒默想要什么，麦康奈尔不想要什么。雷娜和其他“梦想生”正处于想象中最奇怪的立法死胡同。他们的问题非常受欢迎，你本来会认为那是一个资产。但实际上，那是一个诅咒。
Reyna comes to learn that. Flake's seen it already over his many years' negotiating immigration deals.
雷娜开始了解这一点。弗莱克在他多年谈判移民协议的过程中已经见识过了。
We've always had the DREAM Act, or DACA solution, before it was called DACA, that we realized that we could have taken to the floor in either the House and Senate and passed relatively easily because there's so much public support out there. But it was always put as part of the broader package because we needed the other things as well.
在被称为DACA之前，我们一直有“梦想法案”或DACA解决方案，我们意识到我们可以将其带到众议院和参议院，并相对容易地通过，因为外面有太多的公众支持。但它总是作为更广泛方案的一部分，因为我们也需要其他东西。
Because the Dreamers are so popular, they're often used as a spoonful of sugar to make tougher immigration measures easier to swallow-- stuff like border security, restricting visas, or on the Democrat side, legalizing even more immigrants.
因为“梦想生”太受欢迎了，他们经常被当作糖衣，使更严厉的移民措施更容易被接受——比如边境安全、限制签证，或者在民主党那边，使更多移民合法化。
That's the curse of DACA. The most valuable thing about it, on Capitol Hill anyway, is the possibility that it could be used to pass other stuff. So even though we're a democracy, even though 80% of the country wants DACA, the country doesn't get what it wants because there's no incentive for Congress to just put it to a straight up or down vote.
这就是DACA的诅咒。无论如何，在国会山，它最有价值的部分是它可能被用来通过其他东西的可能性。所以尽管我们是一个民主国家，尽管全国80%的人想要DACA，但国家并没有得到它想要的，因为国会没有动机直接进行投票。
And everybody here takes this for granted. So when President Trump canceled DACA in September, DACA become this sort of brass ring again, everyone grabbing at Dreamers for their own agendas. That's why Flake thinks nothing will happen in this White House meeting-- too many people, too many agendas.
而这里每个人都对此习以为常。所以当特朗普总统在九月取消DACA时，DACA又变成了一种“黄铜戒指”，每个人都为了自己的议程抓向“梦想生”。这就是为什么弗莱克认为这次白宫会议不会发生任何事情——人太多，议程太多。
There are people there today who I'm convinced don't want to deal at all. And so anyway, that's what my concern is.
今天在那里的人，我确信根本不想达成任何协议。所以无论如何，这就是我的担忧。
OK, all right. I'll see you when you get back.
好的，好的。等你回来我再找你。
I wasn't allowed into the White House meeting. So I was expecting to just get Flake to tell me later. That proved to be unnecessary.
我不被允许参加白宫会议。所以我预计只是让弗莱克事后告诉我。事实证明那是没必要的。
I'm thrilled to be with a distinguished group of Republican and Democratic lawmakers from both the House and the Senate. We have something in common. We'd like to see this get done.
我很高兴能与来自众议院和参议院的一群杰出的共和党和民主党议员在一起。我们有一个共同点。我们希望看到这件事完成。
It's DACA. We've been talking about DACA for a long--
是DACA。我们已经谈了很久关于DACA的……
There are TVs all over the Senate building tuned to CNN. Chandler, Flake's chief of staff, and I are getting coffee. And notice the cameras aren't leaving the room. All of Washington ends up watching almost the whole meeting on cable TV. This is a pretty infamous meeting talked about a lot since.
参议院大楼的电视上到处都是CNN。弗莱克的幕僚长钱德勒和我正在喝咖啡。请注意，摄像机没有离开房间。华盛顿的所有人最终都在有线电视上观看了几乎整个会议。这是自那时以来被多次提及的一个臭名昭著的会议。
It's one of the starkest moments of reality TV of the Trump presidency. The part at the beginning where everyone's getting along. The president calls a potential deal a "bill of love."
这是特朗普总统任期内最鲜明的真人秀时刻之一。开头每个人都相处得很好的部分。总统称一个潜在的协议为“爱的法案”。
Truly, it should be a bill of love. And we can--
真的，它应该是一项爱的法案。我们可以……
His agenda seems to be prove to everyone he's not crazy. Prove his own tweet that he's a very stable genius. Maybe because of that, he says yes to things he's never wanted before or since.
他的议程似乎是向每个人证明他不疯。证明他自己的推特——他是一个非常稳定的天才。也许正因为如此，他对自己过去从未想过，以后也不会想做的事情说了“是”。
At one point, Senator Feinstein offers a straight-up DACA bill, no wall attached.
在某一点上，范斯坦（Feinstein）参议员提出了一项直接的DACA法案，没有附加墙的要求。
Would you be agreeable to that?
你会同意吗？
Yeah, I would like to. I think a lot of people would like to see that. But I think we have to do DACA.
是的，我愿意。我想很多人都愿意看到这一点。但我认为我们必须做DACA。
But Mr. President, wait.
但总统先生，等等。
Kevin McCarthy, House Republican, is like, no, dude. No. Trump moves on to another guy.
众议院共和党人凯文·麦卡锡（Kevin McCarthy）说，不，伙计。不。特朗普转向另一个人。
Jeff?
杰夫？
Jeff-- I crane my head at the TV to see Flake at the end of the table.
杰夫——我伸长脖子看电视，看到弗莱克在桌子尽头。
For those of us who have been through comprehensive reform, that was six, seven months of every night negotiating.
对于我们这些经历过全面改革的人来说，那可是六、七个月，每晚都在谈判。
He says, doing all the stuff that you're listing that you want, Mr. President, by March 5, that's too hard.
他说，总统先生，您列出的那些想要做的所有事情，要在3月5日之前完成，太难了。
That's why we'd make it a phase two. We do a phase one, which is DACA and security. And we do phase two, which is comprehensive immigration. And I think we should go right to it. I really do. We do one. And we then do the other. But we go right to it, yes.
这就是为什么我们要把它作为一个第二阶段。我们做一个第一阶段，即DACA和安全。我们做一个第二阶段，即全面移民。我想我们应该直接进行。我真的这么认为。我们做一个，然后我们再做另一个。但我们直接进行，是的。
Flake got him to say just what he wanted-- phase one and phase two, DACA and wall first, maybe one or two other things. The bigger, more major changes the White House wants, they'll come later on a separate bill, phase two.
弗莱克让他说了他想要的话——第一阶段和第二阶段，先做DACA和墙，也许还有其他一两件事。白宫想要的更大、更主要的改变，将在稍后的另一项法案中进行，即第二阶段。
After demanding the kitchen sink just a short while ago, Trump's now throwing the kitchen sink out. Everyone in Washington knows that phase two will never happen. Well, Trump doesn't. But Congress knows that Congress cannot pass a comprehensive immigration reform bill.
在刚刚要求一切都要之后，特朗普现在把一切都抛弃了。华盛顿的每个人都知道第二阶段永远不会发生。好吧，特朗普不知道。但国会知道，国会无法通过全面移民改革法案。
But whatever. This will work. It's whiplash but whiplash that Flake thinks breaks his way. I'm not able to meet up with him right after the meeting because he's busy giving TV interviews. When we finally catch up in the Capitol building that afternoon, he's in a completely different mood.
但无论如何。这会奏效的。这是鞭笞，但弗莱克认为这对他是有利的。我没法在会议后立即见到他，因为他忙着接受电视采访。当我们那天下午终于在国会大厦见面时，他的情绪完全不同了。
The news cycle's mood has shifted, too, from alarm over the president's mental state to thrilling over Trump the deal maker. The president's "act like a sane person" strategy seems to be working.
新闻周期的情绪也发生了转变，从对总统心理状态的警觉转变为对作为交易者的特朗普的兴奋。总统的“表现得像个理智的人”策略似乎奏效了。
Have we talked since the meeting or no?
我们会议后谈过吗，还是没谈？
Nope. No, that was all the other reporters.
没有。不，那是其他记者。
Sorry you weren't there. You weren't there. Where you been?
很抱歉你没在场。你不在。你去哪了？
I couldn't get to the White House, man. Luckily, the whole meeting was recorded.
我没法去白宫，伙计。幸运的是，整个会议都有记录。
Aw, man. Woo!
哎呀，伙计。呜！
What'd you make of it?
你觉得怎么样？
Frankly, I had pretty low expectations going into it. But there were some useful things that came out of it. Yeah, he expressed more flexibility than some in the room were comfortable with, I think.
坦率地说，我在参加之前期望很低。但从中产生了一些有用的东西。是的，他表达了比房间里某些人感到舒服的更大的灵活性，我想。
And then when the cameras left, he kept referring to phase one and phase two. And that's what we've been wanting.
然后当摄像机离开时，他一直在提到第一阶段和第二阶段。这就是我们一直想要的。
When I heard that, I thought that was the thing that you've been asking for.
当我听到这个时，我想那就是你一直要求的。
Yeah, it was. Yeah, we talked during the private meeting. That's when I kept trying to come back to him. Thank you for recognizing that we can't do it all in the next month, that we've got to stick to certain items. And then we can come back to the other things.
是的，确实。是的，我们在私人会议期间谈过。那时我一直试图回到他身边。谢谢你认识到我们不能在下个月内完成所有事情，我们必须坚持某些项目。然后我们可以回到其他事情上。
Flake's doing a thing here that I saw a few times. He's such an accentuate-the-positive kind of guy, it's almost like he only heard the parts he wanted to hear. At the meeting, Trump also talked about not letting in killers and ending chain migration. That that was urgent. But Flake's focused on this one point.
弗莱克在这里做了一件我见过几次的事情。他是一个强调积极面的人，几乎就像他只听到了他想听的部分。在会议上，特朗普也谈到了不让杀手进来和结束链式移民。他说那很紧急。但弗莱克专注于这一点。
He made it clear a number of times that he's not going to be doctrinaire on this, more in transient, that he will sign whatever gets to him. That he trusts us to put something together, and that he'll sign it.
他多次明确表示，他不会在这个问题上教条，而是变通，他会签署任何送到他手上的东西。他信任我们去整理一些东西，他会签署它。
I mean, you sound kind of excited. You seem like--
我是说，你听起来有点兴奋。你似乎……
Yeah, a little better.
是的，好一点了。
During my months with Jeff Flake, one thing I didn't understand for a long time was his ability to stay optimistic after years of disappointment over this issue. It was confounding. I knew that part of his optimism is political strategy. He's using that attitude with reporters, with the administration, with his colleagues.
在我与杰夫·弗莱克在一起的几个月里，有一件事我长期不理解，那就是他在这个问题上经历多年失望后保持乐观的能力。这令人困惑。我知道他的部分乐观主义是政治策略。他与记者、行政部门、同事使用那种态度。
But he came to realize at the same time this is his nature. He can't be different. A few months ago, I asked him about The Book of Mormon. I saw it on his desk. I saw him reading from it on his phone and listening to the audio book through wireless headphones.
但他同时意识到这是他的本性。他无法改变。几个月前，我问他关于《摩门经》的事。我看到它在他桌上。我看到他在手机上读它，并通过无线耳机听有声读物。
He's devout. He doesn't drink coffee. He goes to church every Sunday. Doesn't drink or swear. And he told me one of his favorite parts of The Book of Mormon is in the last several passages of Alma, which tells the story of people who, Mormons believe, lived in the Americas long before Columbus arrived. There's a character called Moroni, a military captain.
他是虔诚的。他不喝咖啡。他每周日去教堂。不喝酒也不骂人。他告诉我他最喜欢《摩门经》的部分是在阿尔玛书（Alma）的最后几章，讲述了摩门教徒认为在哥伦布到达之前很久就生活在美洲的人们的故事。有一个角色叫摩罗乃（Moroni），一名军事统帅。
And he grew pretty angry at the government at that time led by a guy named Pahoran, who was a good guy. But Moroni who was also a really good guy, assumed that the government was holding out, not giving them their war supplies and whatever else.
他对自己那个时代由一个叫帕霍兰（Pahoran）的人领导的政府感到相当愤怒，帕霍兰是个好人。但也是个好人的摩罗乃，认为政府在阻挠，没有给他们战争补给和其他东西。
He writes a threatening letter to Pahoran, saying, why are you ignoring me? Long story short, it's a misunderstanding. Pahoran was under siege by the enemy and just couldn't help Moroni. But Moroni had no way of knowing that.
他给帕霍兰写了一封威胁信，说，你为什么无视我？简而言之，这是一个误解。帕霍兰正处于敌人的围困之中，只是无法帮助摩罗乃。但摩罗乃无法知道这一点。
Finally, Pahoran got a chance to tell him. And he didn't get mad at Moroni or anything.
最后，帕霍兰有机会告诉了他。他没有对摩罗乃生气之类的。
He said, no, you're a good man. And you just don't have all the information. They were both fine after that. They reconciled. Something like that tells you to bridle your passions, not assume the worst. Assume the best. Look for the good. Things usually work out.
他说，不，你是个好人。你只是没有所有的信息。他们之后都很好。他们和解了。像这样的事情告诉你控制你的激情，不要假设最坏的情况。假设最好的。寻找美好。事情通常会解决。
Assume the best. Look for the good. It's his motto. He talks about it a lot. It was written out on an index card on his parent's fridge growing up. He says, you'll find it in every one of his 10 brothers and sisters houses, too. It's his attitude towards everyone, even Trump, who Flake can't stand.
假设最好的。寻找美好。这是他的座右铭。他经常谈论它。它写在他父母长大的冰箱上的一张索引卡上。他说，你也会在他10个兄弟姐妹的房子里的每一处找到它。这是他对待每个人的态度，即使是弗莱克无法忍受的特朗普。
Throughout this whole negotiation, Flake continues to say, Trump wants a DACA deal. He has better instincts on this than his advisors, he says. It's the Moroni in him.
在整个谈判过程中，弗莱克继续说，特朗普想要一份DACA协议。他说，他在这一点上有比他的顾问更好的直觉。这是他身上的摩罗乃特质。
When I come in the next morning, January 10, I find out Flake's been up most of the night.
当我第二天早上，1月10日进来时，我发现弗莱克几乎一夜没睡。
Good morning.
早上好。
Good morning. Where have you been?
早上好。你去哪了？
Since the president has said he'll sign whatever he gets, different factions of lawmakers start writing their own bills with their own priorities. It's a race to get a bill to the president and prejudice him in favor of the first one he sees.
自从总统说他会签署任何他得到的东西以来，立法者的不同派系开始编写他们自己的带有自己优先事项的法案。这是一场将法案送到总统手中，并在他看到的第一份法案中偏袒它的竞赛。
You missed a good DACA meeting last night.
你错过了昨晚的一个好的DACA会议。
I did?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Well, what happened?
好吧，发生了什么？
It was just called kind of on the fly. But we met, the six of us. And it's what the group has become.
它只是临时召集的。但我们见面了，我们六个人。这就是这个小组已经变成的样子。
The Gang of Six, all immigration bill veterans, half Democrats, half Republicans. Flake's staff spends the day finishing the draft of the bill. Flake's feeling good about it. Really good. At one point, a bunch of students come by.
“六人帮”，都是移民法案的老手，一半民主党人，一半共和党人。弗莱克的员工花了一整天时间完成了法案的草案。弗莱克对此感觉不错。真的很好。在某一点上，一群学生路过。
--that you will not be running for re-election. So with that, what do you want your legacy to be as senator?
……你将不会参加连任竞选。那么，你希望作为参议员的遗产是什么？
[CHUCKLES] Get DACA done. That's it. That's for Zoe's benefit right here.
[轻笑] 完成DACA。就是这样。那是为了佐伊的利益在这里。
Yeah, no, I appreciate it. I took a note.
是的，不，我很感激。我记下来了。
He's a little tired of me asking about his legacy all the time. So I did appreciate it. By that night, in his office, he's dreaming big. He's imagining the president selling the deal at the State of the Union in 2 and 1/2 weeks.
他对我一直问他的遗产有点厌倦。所以我确实很感激。那天晚上，在他的办公室里，他梦想很大。他想象总统在2周半后的国情咨文中兜售这份协议。
And for the State of the Union address coming up at the end of the month, the president-- it sure would be nice for him to stand up and say, we've got this bipartisan deal done. I'm sure the president wants to do that. I would if I were him.
对于月底即将到来的国情咨文演讲，总统——他站起来说，我们已经完成了这份两党协议，肯定会很好。我肯定总统想这样做。如果我是他，我会的。
I mean, the president's only going to endorse a bipartisan deal. We just hope he'll get behind this one. And we can move it through quickly.
我的意思是，总统只会支持两党协议。我们只是希望他能支持这一项。我们可以快速推进它。
And you think the President will only endorse a bipartisan deal? It's hard to know what he's going to do, right?
你认为总统只会支持两党协议？很难知道他会做什么，对吧？
I do think that he's there.
我确实认为他就在那里。
OK, so you guys, you have your deal.
好的，所以你们，你们有协议。
Right.
没错。
Is it written down on a piece of paper?
它是写在纸上的吗？
I have three sheets that-- I have three sheets here which talk about what we've agreed to.
我有三张纸，谈论我们同意的内容。
Just then, Senator Bob Corker shows up. Like it's the "attack the president and quit the Senate" club meeting.
就在这时，鲍勃·科克参议员出现了。就像是“攻击总统并退出参议院”俱乐部的会议。
Hey, guys.
嘿，伙计们。
Senator.
参议员。
How are you?
你好吗？
Hey.
嘿。
Chief of Staff Chandler basically hooks my collar and literally throws me out of the room.
幕僚长钱德勒基本上勾住我的领子，直接把我扔出了房间。
Whoa, what?
哇，什么？
I grabbed you out of there.
我把你从那里抓出来了。
Why? Because Corker was like, why don't you stay? I was like, I have some place to go.
为什么？因为科克说，你为什么不留下来？我说，我有地方要去。
That's not what happened.
那不是发生的事。
Rude.
粗鲁。
I sit next to the coat rack behind a scheduler and wait. I'm holding the immigration deal outline in my hand. For one sweet Washington moment, I am the only reporter who has it, I think. I fight the urge to tweet it out. It's an urge I never thought I'd have. But being down here, it becomes a thing.
我坐在调度员后面的衣帽架旁边等待。我手里拿着移民协议的大纲。在华盛顿的一个甜蜜时刻，我想我是唯一拥有它的记者。我克制住发推特的冲动。我从没想过我会有这种冲动。但来到这里，这成了一回事。
I read the bill and realize there's so much in here for each side to hate. DACA kids get citizenship but only after 12 years. They aren't allowed to sponsor their parents for citizenship. But the parents do get work permits.
我读了法案，意识到这里有很多让双方都讨厌的内容。DACA孩子获得公民身份，但只有在12年后。他们不允许赞助他们的父母获得公民身份。但父母确实获得了工作许可。
Republicans get an end to the visa lottery program. And Democrats keep those visas for other immigrants. And there's money for the wall. In other words, it's a compromise. Corker leaves. I'm back in. Flake's leaned way back in his chair, his feet up on the desk, on the phone with Dick Durbin. They're cracking each other up.
共和党人获得结束签证抽签计划。而民主党人为其他移民保留了这些签证。而且有隔离墙的钱。换句话说，这是一个妥协。科克离开了。我又回来了。弗莱克向后靠在椅子上，双脚放在桌子上，在电话里和迪克·德宾通话。他们正在让对方大笑。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
For this one moment, it really seems like this is going to work, like Washington is going to work. They're going to do something.
在这一个时刻，它看起来确实会奏效，就像华盛顿会奏效一样。他们要做点什么。
[LAUGHS] Oh, that's great.
[笑声] 哦，那太棒了。
At the end of the night, we get on the Senate subway back to the Capitol Building.
那天晚上结束时，我们坐上参议院地铁回到国会大厦。
Let me put it this way. You've been through this before. So what's going to blow this up?
让我这么说。你以前经历过这个。那么，什么会把这一切炸毁？
What's going to blow this up?
什么会把这一切炸毁？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
If the president hears from the base. Some people get in the White House and see him and say, you can't do this.
如果总统听到了基地的声音。有些人进入白宫，见到他，说，你不能这么做。
Which is exactly what happened.
这正是发生的事情。
Zoe Chace. Coming up, Flake's prophecy fulfilled plus a trip to the South Pacific. That's in a minute. Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
佐伊·蔡斯。接下来，弗莱克的预言实现了，还有一次去南太平洋的旅行。那一分钟后。芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, if you're just tuning in, we're following Senator Jeff Flake as he tries to do the most basic part of his job, and that is pass a law. That's what we pay those guys for. They seem to do it so rarely these days.
《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，如果你刚刚调入，我们正在追踪杰夫·弗莱克参议员，因为他试图完成他工作中最重要的部分，那就是通过一项法律。我们付钱给那些家伙就是为了那个。他们最近似乎很少这样做。
At the end of the first half of the show, we left Senator Flake in a happy, optimistic mood. He had an outline to a bipartisan DACA deal in hand. It addressed four issues the White House had laid out a few days before. The president seemed open. He said he'd sign anything. The plan going forward was this. Lindsey Graham, who'd been playing a lot of golf with the president lately and talking about what good friends they are, would sell the deal to the president.
在节目上半场结束时，我们把弗莱克参议员留在一个快乐、乐观的心情中。他手里拿着一份两党DACA协议的大纲。它解决了白宫几天前提出的四个问题。总统似乎很开放。他说他会签署任何东西。未来的计划是这样的。林赛·格雷厄姆，最近和总统打了很多高尔夫球，并谈论他们是多好的朋友，会把协议卖给总统。
And they would get the president to sell the deal to the American people, which means at this point, none of the senators are supposed to talk about the deal publicly, not yet, because they want Donald Trump to own this deal and sell it. That's the only way the House of Representatives and the Republican base is going to go for the deal.
他们会让总统把协议卖给美国人民，这意味着在这一点上，没有参议员应该公开谈论协议，还不行，因为他们想让唐纳德·特朗普拥有这个协议并卖掉它。这是众议院和共和党基地会接受该协议的唯一方式。
And this brings us to Act Three, Flake's next at bat-- When the Cat's Away, the Mouse, He Can Run Around. Again, here's Zoe Chace.
这把我们带到了第三幕，弗莱克的下一次尝试——当猫不在家时，老鼠会乱跑。再次，这是佐伊·蔡斯。
I wake up the next morning to mass confusion. Somehow or other, the strategy has gone off the rails. I'm on the House side doing another interview, but it's easy to track Flake. He seems to be going from reporter to reporter, saying they have a deal. I'm reading this on Twitter. Eventually he shows up on TV.
第二天早上，我在大规模的困惑中醒来。无论如何，策略已经脱轨了。我在众议院那边做另一个采访，但很容易追踪弗莱克。他似乎从一个记者走到另一个记者面前，说他们有协议。我在推特上读到这个。最终他出现在电视上。
The fact that there is a deal came from Senator Jeff Flake of Arizona.
达成协议的事实来自亚利桑那州的杰夫·弗莱克参议员。
An agreement that we're-- the bipartisan group I'm talking about, the six of us working, that we're shopping among our colleagues now.
一个协议，我们——我谈论的两党小组，我们六个人工作，我们现在在我们的同事中推销。
This was not the plan. Flake knows his name on the deal could kill the deal for the president. He often flies to Arizona as soon as he can on Thursdays. He's incredibly close to his wife, Cheryl. The youngest of his five kids is a senior in high school.
这不是计划。弗莱克知道他在协议上的名字可能会扼杀总统的协议。他经常在周四尽可能快地飞往亚利桑那州。他和他妻子谢丽尔非常亲密。他五个孩子中最小的一个是高中四年级。
I'm basically running with him to get to the airport.
我基本上是在跑着陪他去机场。
So you're running around the capitol saying you've got a deal.
所以你在国会大厦到处说你有协议。
Yeah.
是的。
Why are you doing that?
你为什么要那样做？
As we rush out to the car waiting to take him to the airport, Flake's press officer runs after us, pulls him back, and literally whispers into his ear. It's weird. I've never seen them do that before. We get in the car. I don't know if it's vanity or strategy that's making Flake talk out of school.
当我们冲向等待带他去机场的车时，弗莱克的媒体官追着我们，把他拉回来，并对他耳语。这很怪。我从来没见过他们那样做。我们上了车。我不知道是虚荣心还是策略让弗莱克说话不慎。
Drive slow. What were you doing today?
开慢点。你今天在做什么？
Oh, man.
哦，伙计。
Why did you do that?
你为什么要那样做？
Why did I do what?
为什么我做了什么？
Why did you tell everyone you had a deal?
为什么你告诉每个人你有协议？
Because we have an agreement. We do. We do. The six of us-- between us. We had the agreement.
因为我们有一个协议。我们有。我们有。我们六个人——在我们之间。我们有了协议。
I know. I just thought that you were going to wait for the president to talk about it before you talked about it.
我知道。我只是以为你会在总统谈论它之前等待，在你谈论它之前。
All I said is we pretty much have an agreement when I was asked about it. That's not going rogue I wouldn't think. I've gone rogue. This wasn't rogue.
我所说的只是当被问及此事时，我们几乎有了协议。我不认为那是在乱来。我乱来了。这不是乱来。
It was a little vanity and a little strategy. Flake had been watching Fox News the night before to get a read on how the president's base was taking the immigration developments-- badly, it turns out. After one day of praising his presidential-ness and deal making chops, they were now furious at him for selling out to "Flake Jeff Flake" and the Chuck Schumers of the world.
这有一点虚荣，有一点策略。弗莱克前一天晚上一直在看福克斯新闻，以了解总统的基地是如何看待移民发展的——结果很糟糕。在赞扬他的总统风度和交易能力一天后，他们现在对他因为把他们出卖给“弗莱克杰夫·弗莱克”和世界上的查克·舒默们而感到愤怒。
Flake figured the deal might die then if it was getting brutalized on Fox. So he wanted to make the deal public to keep it alive at least among other members of Congress. As he's explaining all this, he gets a call.
弗莱克认为，如果它在福克斯上受到残酷对待，协议可能会死。所以他想让协议公开，至少在国会的其他成员中保持它活着。当他解释这一切时，他接到了一个电话。
OK. But for the record, I never even said that. I never used the word. [LAUGHS]. OK. All right. Sounds good. Bye.
好的。但为了记录，我从来没有那样说。我从来没用过那个词。[笑声]。好的。好的。听起来不错。再见。
You OK? What's happening?
你还好吗？发生什么事了？
Nothing we can talk about on tape.
没什么我们能在录音带上说的。
The whisper, this call-- something weird is going on. There's something Flake's not telling me.
那个低语，那个电话——有些怪事正在发生。有些事弗莱克没告诉我。
All right. I don't ever like to go off the record with you because I don't want to set a precedent-- but I just want to know if there's anything I should be prepared for.
好的。我从来不喜欢和你离线录音，因为我不想开先例——但我只是想知道是否有我应该准备的事情。
I put the mic down. The president said something unflattering to the president, Flake says to me. Like, the president said something that would make him look really bad if it got out. And with that, he walks over to the airport.
我放下麦克风。总统对总统说了些不好听的话，弗莱克对我说。就像，总统说了一些如果传出去会让他看起来很糟糕的话。说完，他走到机场。
My mind raced through what this president could possibly have said that would be that bad. And I will not share those thoughts with you. Because anyway, 139 minutes later, we all found out.
我的大脑飞速运转，想着这位总统可能说了什么会有那么糟。我不会和你分享那些想法。因为无论如何，139分钟后，我们都发现了。
They all are s-hole people who live in s-hole places. S-hole--
他们都是“粪坑”人，住在“粪坑”地方。粪坑……
[BEEP]-hole countries.
[哔]-洞国家。
All countries in Africa are [BEEP]-holes.
非洲所有的国家都是[哔]-洞。
Why do we want these people from, quote, "All these [BEEP]-hole countries here."
我们为什么要想要这些人，引用，“所有这些[哔]-洞国家”的人在这里。
There was no coming back from that. The deal was dead. Flake didn't mess it up by blabbing about it. In fact, it went down exactly like Flake predicted the night before.
从那之后就没有回头路了。协议死了。弗莱克并没有因为到处乱说而搞砸它。事实上，它发生的过程完全像弗莱克前一天晚上预测的那样。
Some people get in the White House and see him, and say, you can't do this.
有些人进入白宫，见到他，说，你不能这么做。
We even know exactly when it must have happened-- between 10:00 and noon that morning. Because at 10, when Dick Durbin called the president, Donald Trump seemed psyched to hear from him. He wanted to hear what they came up with.
我们甚至确切地知道它一定是在什么时候发生的——在那天上午10点到中午之间。因为在10点，当迪克·德宾给总统打电话时，唐纳德·特朗普似乎对接到他的电话感到兴奋。他想听到他们想出了什么。
So Durbin and Lindsey Graham went over to the White House. There's been a ton of good reporting on this. So you may know the story. By noon, when they arrived, the president was a different guy. Graham and Durbin walk in.
所以德宾和林赛·格雷厄姆去了白宫。关于这个有大量的良好报道。所以你可能知道这个故事。到中午，当他们到达时，总统是一个不同的人。格雷厄姆和德宾走了进去。
And there are hardliners in the room-- Senators Tom Cotton and David Perdue, and from the White House, the chief of staff, the Head of Homeland Security, and Stephen Miller, the anti-immigration obsessed mastermind, the president's domestic policy advisor.
房间里有强硬派——汤姆·科顿（Tom Cotton）和戴维·珀杜（David Perdue）参议员，以及来自白宫的幕僚长，国土安全部负责人，和史蒂芬·米勒（Stephen Miller），那个反移民痴迷的策划者，总统的国内政策顾问。
The president was in a bad mood. Everyone was. "Why do we have all these people coming from [BEEP]-hole countries in Africa," he said, "And not from places like Norway?" And now Trump hates the proposal.
总统心情不好。每个人都心情不好。“为什么我们有所有这些人来自非洲的‘粪坑’国家，”他说，“而不是来自像挪威这样的地方？”现在特朗普讨厌这个提案。
In the space of two days, he's gone from wanting the kitchen sink in exchange for DACA to wanting a bill of love, DACA and the wall and a few other things. Now he was back to wanting the kitchen sink.
在两天的时间里，他从想要一切换取DACA，到想要一项爱的法案，DACA和墙以及其他几件事。现在他又回到了想要一切。
This is not how this is supposed to go. Usually the president signals to the Congress what he wants to do. The Congress signals to the president what they might pass. When it's the same party, those priorities line up. And they march along like a three-legged race, pushing and pulling a little bit but headed towards a common goal, like say Obama on Obamacare.
这不是它应该走的方式。通常总统向国会发出他想做什么的信号。国会向总统发出他们可能通过什么的信号。当是同一个政党时，这些优先事项排成一行。他们像三条腿比赛一样前进，推拉一点，但朝着一个共同的目标前进，比如奥巴马在奥巴马医改上。
This is a Republican Congress that can't move in sync with this White House because looking for signals from this White House, it's like a flaming, screaming siren of noise. As demonstrated this week, every new person who walks into the Oval Office can flip the president to their side.
这是一个无法与白宫同步前进的共和党国会，因为寻找来自白宫的信号，就像一个尖叫的火焰警笛声。正如本周所证明的那样，每一个走进椭圆形办公室的新人都可能把总统转向他们那一边。
Let alone what he sees on TV every morning and every night, you can't get a clear signal from someone who turns on a dime like that. So politics has turned into this game of red light, green light. When the president turns on the green light, everyone runs toward him, trying to make a deal. When he turns on the red light, everyone has to stop.
更不用说他每天早上和每天晚上在电视上看到的东西，你无法从一个那样旋转的人那里得到清晰的信号。所以政治已经变成了这个红灯、绿灯的游戏。当总统打开绿灯时，每个人都跑向他，试图达成协议。当他打开红灯时，每个人都必须停下来。
You can't build up momentum towards anything. You can't find a compromise that'll please him. In that environment, what's a senator to do?
你无法建立对任何事情的动力。你无法找到一个能让他满意的妥协。在这种环境下，参议员能做什么？
Act Four, It's Our Prerogative. In the weeks after [BEEP]-hole, I started to hear Flake using a word I find shocking coming out of his mouth.
第四幕，这是我们的特权。在“粪坑”事件后的几周里，我开始听到弗莱克使用一个我觉得从他嘴里说出来很令人震惊的词。
[CHUCKLES] It's just frustrating.
[轻笑] 真是令人沮丧。
The more Flake has lived with this red light, green light thing, the more he's decided that's not what the Senate exists to do. The regular process of waiting to hear what the president wants and respond to it-- in normal times, that might make sense.
弗莱克与这个红灯、绿灯的事情生活得越久，他越觉得那不是参议院存在要做的事情。等待听到总统想要什么并回应它的常规过程——在正常时期，那可能有意义。
But Flake's like, this guy is nutty and changes every five minutes. And we don't have to do that. We have the power to force this president into committing to something.
但弗莱克像说，这人是疯子，每五分钟就改变主意。我们不必那样做。我们有力量迫使这位总统承诺某件事。
Well, we're an equal branch of government here. And we've been acting like we're not. But I do think that if we-- we'll actually pass something here. And I believe it will be the bipartisan bill, the one in the middle. Then the president will find a way to like it.
嗯，我们这里是一个平等的政府部门。而我们表现得好像我们不是。但我确实认为，如果我们——我们会在这里通过一些东西。我相信它将是两党法案，中间的那一个。然后总统会找到一种方法去喜欢它。
But we just can't wait and can't just give away our prerogative here. And that's what we've been doing. And it's just not right.
但我们只是不能等待，不能放弃我们在这里的特权。而这就是我们一直在做的。这根本不对。
Flake's vision is this-- if the Senate passes something with 60 votes, especially something like DACA, it'll force the president to like it. This is what happened with the Russia sanctions bill. The president didn't want to impose sanctions, at least the way Congress was demanding.
弗莱克的愿景是这样的——如果参议院通过了60票的东西，特别是像DACA这样的东西，它会迫使总统喜欢它。这就是俄罗斯制裁法案发生的事情。总统不想实施制裁，至少不是国会要求的方式。
Then the Senate and the House voted overwhelmingly to do it. And he signed it reluctantly. He signed it, quote, for the sake of national unity. And once the president says yes, Jeff Flake thinks, even if a bill seems too liberal for the House, the House will just go along with the president because that's what they do.
然后参议院和众议院以压倒性多数投票这样做。他勉强签署了。他签署它，引用，为了民族团结。Jeff Flake认为，一旦总统说是，即使法案对众议院来说似乎太自由，众议院也会跟随总统，因为他们就是那样做的。
The key is in the end, what Trump could call an apple and an orange, and the House would buy it, I think. I would say that. So it just depends on him.
关键是最后，特朗普可以称之为苹果和橙子，而众议院会买账，我想。我会这么说。所以这只取决于他。
This is not Mitch McConnell's idea of how things should work. Remember that innocent phrase he uttered back in December?
这不是米奇·麦康奈尔认为事情应该如何运作的想法。还记得他在十二月说的那个无辜的短语吗？
An agreement that the administration is comfortable with.
行政部门感到舒适的协议。
He'll only bring a bill to the floor that the White House supports. Blake said that was never part of the deal. But he says that's generally been McConnell's approach with this president. Only bring stuff to a vote that the president wants to sign.
他只会将白宫支持的法案提交到议会。布莱克说那从来不是协议的一部分。但他说那是麦康奈尔与这位总统的一般做法。只把总统想要签署的东西付诸表决。
January 19-- it's been one month since McConnell's commitment to bring DACA to the floor in January. And he shows no intention of bringing up DACA. In fact, he's made it clear he will not. And the entire US government is about to come to a standstill over this disagreement.
1月19日——距离麦康奈尔在1月将DACA提交到议会的承诺已经一个月了。他没有表现出提交DACA的意图。事实上，他已经明确表示他不会。而整个美国政府正因为这种分歧而陷入停滞。
The Democrats have watched Flake get burned by McConnell. And now they step forward with their own moves to try to force DACA to the floor. Chuck Schumer goes to the White House and, over cheeseburgers, tries to cut a quick last minute deal with the president-- $25 billion for the wall in exchange for DACA. A huge sum, more than the White House has ever publicly asked for. Trump rejects it.
民主党人看着弗莱克被麦康奈尔烧伤。现在他们迈步向前，用他们自己的动作试图强迫DACA进入议会。查克·舒默去了白宫，并在芝士汉堡上，试图与总统达成快速最后一分钟的协议——250亿美元换取DACA。一笔巨大的金额，比白宫公开要求的任何时候都多。特朗普拒绝了。
So Democrats set their sights on McConnell. They tell them to bring DACA to the floor or they'll shut the government down. They won't vote for the spending bill that comes before the Senate that night. McConnell doesn't budge.
所以民主党人把目光投向麦康奈尔。他们告诉他们将DACA提交到议会，否则他们将关闭政府。他们不会投票支持那天晚上提交到参议院的支出法案。麦康奈尔没有动摇。
You know how this ends. The government shuts down. But watching them try to avoid it at the last minute that night was kind of wild. I watched from the Senate press gallery. All the congressional reporters were pressed together on this balcony above the Senate floor.
你知道这是怎么结束的。政府关闭了。但那天晚上看着他们试图在最后一分钟避免它真是太疯狂了。我从参议院新闻画廊观看。所有的国会记者都挤在参议院楼层上方的这个阳台上。
They were telling me this is rare. You barely ever see this, watching them negotiate in public in front of you. You're so close, you feel like you should be able to hear them. But you can't, so you watch closely. The senators head to the floor for a vote around 10:15 that night. And they stay out there till after 1:00 AM.
他们告诉我这是罕见的。你几乎从来没见过这个，看着他们在你面前公开谈判。你太近了，你觉得你应该能听到他们。但你不能，所以你仔细看。参议员们在晚上10:15左右前往楼层进行投票。他们一直在那里呆到凌晨1点以后。
The drama all revolves around McConnell and Schumer, who are refusing to talk to each other. These two grown men, who have worked together for years, who are in charge of the Senate, sitting on opposite sides of the room not looking at each other, with all these other grown adults running around them just trying to get them to speak.
戏剧完全围绕着麦康奈尔和舒默，他们拒绝相互交谈。这两个成年男人，多年来一直一起工作，负责参议院，坐在房间的两端，互不相看，所有这些其他成年人在他们周围跑来跑去，只是试图让他们说话。
If it were a ballet, Jeff Flake and Lindsey Graham were the principals, whirling and spinning all over the room between the Democrats and the Republicans, seemingly trying to cut a deal. All the Democrat lady senators, at one point, were gabbing in the corner until Graham bursts in.
如果这是一个芭蕾舞，杰夫·弗莱克和林赛·格雷厄姆是主角，在民主党和共和党之间旋转和旋转整个房间，似乎试图达成协议。所有的民主党女性参议员，在某一点上，都在角落里交谈，直到格雷厄姆冲进来。
Rubio, Cruz, a couple of the other guys, sat in a row in the back like kids smoking cigarettes on the bleachers too cool to engage, cracking each other up. At some point, for no obvious reason, House Republican Dana Rohrabacher wandered onto the floor and veered around, looking bedraggled. But through all this, the two people with the power to stop a shutdown, McConnell and Schumer, they barely budged from their chairs.
卢比奥、克鲁兹，其他几个家伙，坐在后排像在看台上抽烟的孩子，太酷了而无法参与，让对方大笑。在某一点上，由于没有明显的原因，众议院共和党人达纳·罗拉巴克（Dana Rohrabacher）走上了楼层并转弯，看起来很凌乱。但通过这一切，拥有阻止关闭权力的两个人，麦康奈尔和舒默，他们几乎没有从椅子上动弹。
Very sadly, we are on the precipice of a government shutdown.
非常悲伤地，我们正处于政府关闭的悬崖边缘。
Occasionally, they got up and scolded the other one without looking his way.
偶尔，他们站起来责骂对方而不看他的方向。
I think our friends on the other side took some bad advice. Really bad advice. I'd hate to have to be trying to explain this, myself. They held all this hostage, over the completely unrelated issue of illegal immigration.
我认为我们这边的朋友听了一些糟糕的建议。非常糟糕的建议。我不想不得不自己解释这一点。他们以完全无关的非法移民问题为由，把这一切当做人质。
And it ends there.
它在那里结束了。
The Senate stands adjourned until 12:00 noon today.
参议院休会至今天中午12:00。
[GAVEL BANGING]
[木槌敲击]
We meet back in Flake's office at 2:00 AM. His staff is lying on the floor in the dark, watching movies. Flake's hair is spiked up on his head from running his hands through it for hours. See you tomorrow, Flake yells as I leave. He sleeps in his office.
我们凌晨2点在弗莱克的办公室见面。他的员工在黑暗中躺在地板上，看着电影。弗莱克头发竖在头上，因为他用手抓了几个小时。明天见，我离开时弗莱克喊道。他睡在他的办公室里。
Oh, man, the government is shut down, I say to Flake's scheduler on the way out. What a time to be alive, she says back. In the outside world, people are wondering what the shutdown means. Who is going to be furloughed? What's this going to cost?
哦，伙计，政府关闭了，我在离开时对弗莱克的调度员说。活着的时候真是个好时间，她回来说。在外部世界，人们想知道关闭意味着什么。谁将被休假？这会花费什么？
Fox News alert, Uncle Sam turns out the lights. Now the blame game is in full swing as the government shuts down.
福克斯新闻警报，山姆大叔关灯。现在，责备游戏在政府关闭时正在全面展开。
Tension on Capitol Hill following the government shutdown.
政府关闭后，国会山紧张局势。
This is utter madness!
这真是彻底的疯狂！
Meanwhile, inside Congress, it's a really different vibe. It's like a fun sleepover. I pop in on Colorado Senator Michael Bennet. And he's hanging around in his socks. Senators are posting sunset pictures from the Capitol to Twitter. Reporters are tweeting out which Chinese place lunch is from.
与此同时，在国会内部，这真是一个不同的氛围。这就像一个有趣的过夜派对。我顺便去看了科罗拉多州参议员迈克尔·本内特（Michael Bennet）。他穿着袜子四处走动。参议员们正在从国会大厦发布日落图片到推特。记者们正在发布午餐是哪家中国餐馆。
Graham and Flake out to get fajitas. A bipartisan group of senators comes together to end the shutdown. They meet in Susan Collins' office. For the first time in forever, it's like true bipartisan deal making over bagels and coffee. It's exciting. Susan Collins institutes this beaded talking stick. You can't talk in their meetings unless you're holding it.
格雷厄姆和弗莱克去买法希塔。一组两党参议员聚集在一起结束关闭。他们在苏珊·柯林斯的办公室见面。这是永远以来第一次，这就像在百吉饼和咖啡上达成真正的两党协议。这很令人兴奋。苏珊·柯林斯建立了这个串珠谈话棒。你不能在他们的会议上说话，除非你拿着它。
I got it first to talk about what I was proposing the group accept. And then they handed it around till Lamar Alexander got it.
我先拿到它，谈论我建议小组接受什么。然后他们把它传着，直到拉马尔·亚历山大（Lamar Alexander）拿到它。
22 people in there, nine Republicans, 13 Democrats, everyone in a circle. Alexander's talking about Senate process.
22人在那里，9名共和党人，13名民主党人，每个人都在一个圈子里。亚历山大正在谈论参议院流程。
And Mark Warner across the room interrupted him and then interrupted him again. And Lamar, mild mannered Lamar, takes the stick like a javelin, and threw it at--
马克·华纳（Mark Warner）在房间对面打断了他，然后再次打断了他。拉马尔，温和的拉马尔，像标枪一样拿着棍子，把它扔向——
[GASPS]
[喘气]
--at Mark Warner.
……马克·华纳。
Oh my God.
天哪。
Lamar ducked. It hit the wall. You could've heard a pin drop. It was the quietest-- just complete and utter shock. Anyway so, and then the meeting went on for the rest of time. Then today--
拉马尔躲开了。它撞到了墙上。你可以听到针掉的声音。这只是完全彻底的震惊。无论如何，所以，然后会议继续了剩余的时间。然后今天——
Lamar Alexander, channeling the frustration of the entire country over his own powerlessness in that moment.
拉马尔·亚历山大，在那个时刻引导了整个国家对自己无能为力的挫败感。
In the middle of the shutdown,
在关闭期间，
Flake goes to the floor of the Senate and makes a speech trying to rally other senators around his cause, pitching his dream that they don't have to cater to the president. They can pass their own bill and nail the White House down that way.
弗莱克走到参议院的楼层并发表演讲，试图围绕他的事业集结其他参议员，推销他的梦想，即他们不必迎合总统。他们可以传递他们自己的法案，并以那种方式把白宫钉住。
The best way out of this is for the Senate to be the Senate again. We are an equal branch of government. And to say that we won't move on a particular topic until we have agreement from the president when we've waited for weeks and weeks and weeks for that kind of agreement or that kind of nod or signal, we can't wait anymore.
摆脱这种情况的最好方法是让参议院再次成为参议院。我们是平等的政府部门。并且说我们不会在一个特定话题上采取行动，直到我们有总统的协议，当我们已经等了数周又数周的那种协议或那种点头或信号，我们不能再等了。
Let's more jealously guard our prerogative here as legislators. And let's bring an immigration bill to the floor.
让我们更嫉妒地守护我们作为立法者的特权。让我们把移民法案带到楼层。
No one seems to be signing up. That's Flake's issue in general. He seems to talk to an invisible group of Republicans that no one else can see, Republicans who agree with him.
没有人似乎在报名。那是弗莱克大体上的问题。他似乎在和一群隐形的共和党人交谈，其他人看不见，同意他的共和党人。
As you know, the shutdown ends. The final deal is this-- three more weeks of government funding and an agreed upon time for a DACA deal to come to the floor. That's exactly where they were a month ago. McConnell took it away. McConnell gave it back.
如你所知，关闭结束了。最终协议是这样的——再有三周的政府资金，并达成一致的时间让DACA协议进入议会。那正是他们一个月前的位置。麦康奈尔拿走了它。麦康奈尔把它还了回来。
As you also know, DACA has not passed. There is no DACA deal. The one Flake supported, the bipartisan talking stick deal, the Trump administration issued an apocalyptic statement tearing it to shreds. None of the proposals got enough votes to pass.
如你所知，DACA没有通过。没有DACA协议。弗莱克支持的那一个，两党谈话棒协议，特朗普政府发布了一份将其撕碎的启示录声明。没有一个提案得到足够的票数通过。
It's widely acknowledged they'll pass no more bills this year. No more major ones, at least. Jeff Flake failed. For the last few years, Jeff Flake has done this weird, very nonpolitical thing. He goes to a remote Pacific island and lives there for a week to see if he can survive on his own.
公认他们今年不会通过更多的法案。至少没有更多主要的法案。杰夫·弗莱克失败了。在过去的几年里，杰夫·弗莱克做了一件奇怪的、非常非政治的事情。他去了一个偏远的太平洋岛屿，并在那里住了一个星期，看看他是否能独自生存。
He grew up obsessed with survival stories-- his favorite guilty pleasure, he says-- Shackleton, Robinson Crusoe, anyone who was basically in a sailboat, capsized, ended up on a life raft, and got to an island. He wanted to know, if I were marooned on an island, could I survive?
他在沉迷于生存故事中长大——他最喜欢的内疚乐趣，他说——沙克尔顿、鲁滨逊·克鲁索，任何基本上在帆船上、翻船、最终在救生筏上并到达岛屿的人。他想知道，如果我被困在一个岛上，我能生存吗？
He first tried it back in 2009. He went somewhere near the Marshall Islands for a week, lived on spearfishing and coconuts. He got lonely. So he wrote numbers with a Sharpie on the hermit crab shells so he could keep track of them. See which ones were friendly. He liked it so much he went to another island a few years later with two of his kids and then the next year with a Democratic senator to make a point about bipartisanship.
他第一次在2009年尝试。他去了马绍尔群岛附近的某个地方待了一个星期，以鱼叉捕鱼和椰子为生。他感到孤独。所以他用记号笔在寄居蟹壳上写了数字，以便他能跟踪它们。看看哪些是友好的。他非常喜欢它，以至于几年后他又去了另一个岛，和他的两个孩子，然后第二年和一位民主党参议员，为了说明两党合作的重点。
The Discovery Channel filmed it. Called it Rival Survival.
发现频道拍摄了它。叫它“竞争生存”。
The barrel full of life-saving water lies nearby. But unless they can build a fire to purify the contaminated water, they're at risk of acute dehydration.
桶里装满救生水在附近。但是除非他们能生火来净化污染的水，否则他们有急性脱水的风险。
He's a proud Democrat. I'm a proud Republican. But I'd gladly vote for any of Martin's bills if he could just start a fire.
他是一个自豪的民主党人。我是一个自豪的共和党人。但我很乐意投票支持马丁的任何法案，如果他能生火的话。
[SQUEAKING]
[吱吱声]
Aw, come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Flame, flame. Come on.
哎呀，来吧。来吧。来吧。来吧。火焰，火焰。来吧。
Flake and Heinrich never make a fire on the island. They could have just brought matches with them. But they were caught in a reality TV show game where the rules were arbitrary and rigged against doing the obvious, simple thing. You see where I'm going with this.
弗莱克和海因里希（Heinrich）从没在岛上生火。他们本可以带火柴的。但他们陷入了一个真人秀游戏的陷阱，规则是任意的，并且反对做显而易见、简单的事情。你看到我要去哪里了。
It takes a very particular kind of person to put up with rules like that and maintain a go-get-em, can-do attitude, and come back again and again. And Jeff Flake is still at it. Last I saw him, he was bringing a new DACA proposal to the floor. He says he's going to keep bringing it up until it passes.
需要一个非常特殊的人来忍受这样的规则，并保持一种“去办吧”、“能做到的”态度，并且一次又一次地回来。杰夫·弗莱克还在努力。上次见到他时，他正在把一份新的DACA提案带到楼层。他说他会一直把它带出来，直到它通过。
Do you think other senators think it's silly that you're out there still talking about DACA?
你认为其他参议员认为你在外面仍然谈论DACA很愚蠢吗？
Some of them, yeah, probably. Move on, Flake. No, still got time. Still got to do it. I'm excited. This is going to do it. This speech is going to change minds. [LAUGHS]
他们中的一些，是的，可能。继续前进，弗莱克。不，还有时间。还是要去做。我很兴奋。这会做到的。这个演讲会改变想法。[笑声]
I can't tell if you think that or not. I really don't know.
我不能说你是否这么认为。我真的不知道。
I see that it's working. No, I mean, what choice do you have? You move ahead.
我看到它在奏效。不，我是说，你有什么选择？你继续前进。
Maybe he's acting, strategically playing the part of the optimist, pretending things will turn around next week. Maybe he has faith that things will truly turn around next week. After all this time, I still find it hard to tell. There's a little Don Quixote in him for sure.
也许他在演戏，战略性地扮演乐观主义者的角色，假装事情会在下周好转。也许他有信心事情会在下周真正好转。经过这么长时间，我仍然觉得很难说。他身上肯定有一点堂吉诃德。
But there's also a long game that he's playing. And I'm on to it now. He's trying to force his view of governance into being by constantly acting as if things are different from this political reality, that how it is now doesn't have to be the way it always is.
但他也在玩一个长局。我现在明白了。他正试图通过不断表现得好像事情与这种政治现实不同，表现得好像现在的情况不必总是那样，来强迫他的治理观进入存在。
Zoe Chace is one of the producers of our program.
佐伊·蔡斯是我们节目的制片人之一。
Our program is produced today by Ben Calhoun and our senior producer, Brian Reed. Our staff includes Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Alvin Melathe, Nadia Reiman, Lilly Sullivan. Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Susan Burton.
我们的节目今天由本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）和我们的资深制片人布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）制作。我们的员工包括佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德（Whitney Dangerfield）、斯蒂芬妮·富（Stephanie Foo）、查纳·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、戴维·克斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）、赛斯·林德（Seth Lind）、阿尔文·梅拉特（Alvin Melathe）、纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）。克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和黛安·吴（Diane Wu）。我们的执行编辑是苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's cofounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. I caught him two-timing me with another radio host, Kai Ryssdal, the host of Marketplace.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交换中心）发送给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。我抓到他和一个无线电主持人，凯·里斯达尔（Kai Ryssdal），《Marketplace》的主持人，跟我搞双重恋爱。
I finally confronted Torey about it and he said no, no, no, they're just good friends.
我终于就此事与托雷对质，他说不，不，不，他们只是好朋友。
He and I are close. We talk about tax cuts.
我和他是亲密的。我们谈论减税。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。